well it's time sit back and honestly
just prepare yourselves as today we are
going over one of the biggest mind
twisters of a story that i've ever read
like i thought i knew what was going on
but no i i wasn't even close the way
tatsuki fujimoto beautifully had the
true scope of what is actually going on
behind these scenes is utterly sublime
so yes as the title states in today's
video we'll be going over the entire
story of chainsaw man also if you guys
didn't actually know big fujimoto is
doing multiple parts of this series that
we'll be releasing from this month
onwards so technically this is only the
first part of the series like the man's
an actual genius coming back in to
collect the bag while his anime starts
releasing but anyway enough of the goat
himself it's time we get into the eight
arcs that make up part one of chainsaw
man
so as this story starts off we find a
young dingy talking to his chainsaw-like
pet named pogita they continue talking
bringing up how tree cutting and selling
his body parts brings his debt down to
only 38 million and 40 000 yen
then she then turns to pachita saying
let's go and kill something
straight after this we see that he is
hunting a tomato devil using pachita
like a chainsaw dingy explains that
hunting a devil will make him three
hundred thousand dollars which will help
ease his debts for a birds after
destroying the devil then she talks to
an elderly man who tells him that the
devil's worth on the black market is 400
000 yen however dingy's happiness is
soon dashed when the old man tells him
that after subtracting his debt and
other expenses from the total he only
gets 70 000 yen then she then takes his
money from the old man and thinks to
himself that after paying his water bill
he's only left with a measly 1800 and
since denji and pachita have got nothing
to eat at home too their meal for the
day will be a single slice of succulent
bread as this was happening the old man
and his driver were watching him from a
car the driver questions him asking why
did he employ brat as a devil hunter to
which the old man responds that he
employed dingy because his pops died
before he paid back his debt however the
driver still persists and the old man
explains that a real devil hunter
wouldn't just let a yakuza take the
corpse afterwards he then adds on that
the good thing about denji is that he
always does what he is told uncertain of
this the driver yells out and asks
stingy to eat a cigarette for a hundred
yen which he accepts because every penny
matters to him as denji eats a cigarette
the driver speeds away laughing and
saying that they will reach out to him
if there's another devil appearance and
he better not run away because if he
does they will find and kill him upon
them leaving dingy spits out his ziggy
and tells pochita that because of the
hundred yen they will be able to eat for
another three days
later at denji's shack we see the duo
eating a slice of bread and saying that
the normal things in life are just a
dream for him he can't ask a girl over
because of his run-down shack and he
heard that dating is quite expensive
anyway pogchita whines in response and
then she says that if dreams ever come
true then he wants to hug a girl before
he dies
as we flow back into a flashback we see
the kid denji standing in front of his
father's grave who had hung himself
before making his monthly payment to the
yakuza behind denji a younger but still
old man tells him to have his 700
thousand yen ready by tomorrow or he
will cut up dingy and sell the pieces as
the car leaves we see pachita coming out
from behind a tree seemingly to attack
dingy the young boy though accepts his
fate and tells the chainsaw devil to
kill him because he's going to die
either way but pachita doesn't attack
him instead falling to the ground
showing dingy his wounds upon seeing him
dying denji remembers his late father
and decides he doesn't want anyone to
die sitting up he tells pachita to bite
his arm because he heard if a devil
drinks blood its wounds are healed and
if bachita doesn't want to die he has to
do so vegeta bites his arm while denji
screams telling him that their blood
doesn't come for free and that this is a
contract so in return for saving him
pachuda must also help to save denji as
he doesn't want to die either the next
day the old man shows up for the payment
and as denji shows up slaying a devil he
asks the old man if he would hire him as
a devil hunter after the flashback is
over then she lays on the ground saying
he can't fall asleep because he is too
hungry and all he can think about is his
death he tells the little pochita that
he knows what he will dream of tonight
saying that he will flirt with a girl
play video games and fall asleep in her
arms he tells pegita that it's a pretty
great dream to which the pup yapped
happily almost instantly though denji
spewed up blood while at the same time
the old man randomly started banging at
the door saying that there was a devil
then she tells petita that his mother
died of a heart disease which made her
cough up blood as they leave dingy
thinks to himself wanting to just dream
even a little
soon they arrive at the abandoned
building with the devilers then she
questions the old man as he doesn't see
any kind of devil but the old man acts
like he didn't hear dingy and starts
thanking him for being loyal like a dog
hearing this then she starts feeling
awkward however the old man switches on
him telling dingy that he hates the
stench of dogs sadly as dinji was
looking forwards he feels something
pierced through his heart from behind as
he looks backwards he sees a yakuza man
with a short sword had stabbed him and
pochita through the heart the old man
tells dingy that they want power to make
money so they have made a contract with
a devil like he did revealing himself
the monstrous devil stands up with a
bunch of abnormal looking humans around
him while saying that it wants the death
of all devil hunters he goes on to
explain that he the zombie devil has
turned all of these stupid people into
his puppets by making them his zombies
it orders the zombies to kill him and
soon enough these zombies start chasing
the injured duo as he runs dingy thinks
that he just wanted to live a normal
life but no one ever let him have even
that sadly they catch and kill him
brutally slicing him into multiple
pieces and leaving his remains in an
alleyway dumpster
as the blood from denji's nose reaches
pochita's mouth the young devil thinks
about how they were cutting trees and
how dingy had told him that if he dies
fighting demons he would be worried
about what would happen to pachita
wondering if he would die of starvation
or get killed by another devil hunter
though dingy had said he had heard some
devils can take over dead humans bodies
so if pechita is one of them he wants to
give him his body and run away from the
town so that the yakuza won't come after
him
then she says it'd be nice if you can
have a normal life and die a normal
death while telling him to fulfill his
dreams for him
back in reality denji's body can torts
out of place as it slowly gets pulled
back together by bochita who is
connected to his chest seemingly fusing
with him inside of denji's head he has a
dream in which he is lying with pachita
on his chest denji calls pachitta's name
to which pachito responds for the
cheerful wolf then denji asks him if he
has taken over the control of his body
like he had asked him to to which
pachita responds by saying he has always
liked to listen to dingy's dreams then
she is left shocked but before he can
say anything pachita tells him that this
is a contract and that he will give
denji his heart but in exchange then she
has to show him more of his dreams he
then snaps awake calling for pachita but
then he looks down and is shocked seeing
that all of his wounds are gone he then
looks at his chest and finds a cord
protruding from his heart identical to
pachita's tail
screaming he yells out for his little
friend's name
in front of him though we see that all
of these zombies have returned again and
the zombie devil gets shocked seeing
dingy somehow had managed to survive
against the previous attack he instantly
orders these zombies to kill and devour
dingy though just blankly stares at the
mob thinking that all these guys already
had enough and why did they want a
better life but then he wonders if he is
similar and if he should have been happy
as long as he had pages here but he
still wanted a better life as well he
thinks to himself that dreaming is not a
bad thing everybody dreams and it's not
bad too but if they come in the way of
his dreams then they will have to die
dingy rips the kill switch on his chest
harder than a damn blade blade and a
horde of zombies rush at denji and begin
mauling him the zombie devil pipes up
saying to himself and the horde the
dingy has got to be dead after they ate
him but suddenly we see a zombie being
teared vertically apart by a chainsaw
dingy then reveals himself tearing
through the crowd of zombies fused with
pochita to become the one and only
chainsaw man the zombie devil tries to
say to dingy that they are the same but
gets completely ignored and then she
cuts through its eye then continues to
tear the devil apart easily with his
blades turning around he notices the
zombie horde have turned into devils and
since he is a devil hunter he's got to
destroy them all he literally starts
slicing his way through them one by one
then laughing like an actual madman as
he ruthlessly takes out the rest saying
that if he kills every single one of
them then he can say goodbye to his debt
a while later a car pulls up outside of
the abandoned building and three people
and suits come inside the girl notes
that it looks like someone has beaten us
to the punch as they realize that the
entire horde has been completely
obliterated as they look around and see
only one remaining devil standing there
one of these suits says that they've got
a living one however the mysterious girl
walks up to denji and says that he has a
peculiar smell
it isn't devil or human
she then asks him if he did all of this
but instead denji was too worn out and
he begins to throw up blood from his
mouth
while collapsing he asks the girl to
hold him but before he even realizes the
girl hugs dingy instead of holding him
and dingy's chainsaw form starts losing
its solidity
seeing him like this the girl says that
she knows he's a human one of the suits
ask the girl if he is possessed by a
devil to which she responds no because
you can see the possession on their
faces the girl then responds tell dingy
who was in her hands that she came here
to kill the zombie devil and as a public
safety devil hunter she offers dengy two
choices that he can either be killed by
her as a devil or be kept by her as a
pet human
she tells him as a pet he will get given
food in which then she asks her food and
a little surprised voice and what kind
of food would he get for breakfast
the girl answers while thinking that he
can have bread with jam salad coffee and
even more hearing he would be getting
bread with jam though and other things
for breakfast then she agrees saying
that it sounds like heaven before
collapsing
as time moves forward we see that denchi
has woken up and is heading somewhere
with the devil hunters his stomach
continues gurgling and he says that he
hasn't eaten to which the girl responds
that they haven't had breakfast either
so they might as well go and grab some
food upon hearing this denji awkwardly
says that he's broke and can't afford
the food to which the girl says that he
can pick whatever he wants and she will
pay for it then she is left shocked but
before talking the girl gives dingy her
code saying he will draw people's
attention walking around shirtless after
putting on the jacket then she peeks
over at the girl and thinks to himself
that people had always called him dirty
and smelly but with this girl it's the
first time he's ever been treated so
nicely and on top of that by a pretty
girl as well with all this then she
comes to a realization that he truly is
in love with her
soon they arrive at a shop where they
order their food but suddenly a random
man runs in bleeding and yelling at the
cashier to help him the suit girl tells
him that she is a devil hunter and asks
him to explain what has happened the man
screams that a devil has kidnapped his
daughter and taken her into the woods at
the same time the chef comes up and then
tells them that their udon is ready to
watch the girl thinks for a while and
asks stingy what his name is obviously
denji tells her his name and she tells
him that she doesn't want her udon to
get soggy instead he will have to go and
kill the devil himself then she responds
that he's also having food though and
while quietly mumbling this he overhears
one of the devil hunters say that an
extremely experienced devil hunter is on
the job cutting him off she then asks
dingy if he forgot that he is her peers
and the only response that she wants is
a yes or a wolf as she doesn't need a
dog who says no
then she asks what she means in an
unsure voice to what she intensely says
that she has heard from a judge that in
the crime division they euthanize
useless dogs while he's terrified denji
stands there the girl tells him to get
to work fast before her noodles becomes
soggy and asks him what his answer was
to which he distraught dingy responds by
saying yes
as he runs off into the woods thinking
about how the girl was nice to the point
that he even liked her a little however
he now realizes that she is just a damn
psycho who is also treating him just
like a dog while thinking he gets
reminded of pogisa and how he had died
then he suddenly hears the voice of a
girl he heads over to where the voice
was coming from and finds the girl he's
after with a little devil instantly
after noticing him the young girl
confronts stingy asking him to let the
little devil go
she proceeds to tell dingy that her dad
had beaten her up but this nice devil
came and saved her she pleads for him
not to kill it
upon hearing this then she starts
thinking what should he do and after a
somewhat difficult decision then she
tells the girl that they all three can
run away if they want and he also had a
friendship with a devil so he knows that
not all devils are evil the girl asks
didn't she if they can really run to
what she says that they totally can
however as the girl claps denshi's hand
and they all start laughing the girl's
face starts deforming slightly all of a
sudden dingy finds himself getting
lifted up and looks to find out that
it's the devil's actual form which are
transformed into a terrifying worm-like
devil shocked then she wonders what the
hell had just happened and the devil
tells him that he will show him
something cool before he dies and that
instead of a worm he's actually the
muscle demon he proceeds to manipulate
denji's arm he says that he can control
muscles and taunts him even more with
the girl's mouth saying how you'll mess
with the little girl he begins messing
with the girl's face will or mahinu
cackle throughout his entire attack
however denji lets out a little giggle
and then rips his kill switch with his
mouth almost instantly decimating the
muscle demon with his chainsaws then she
yells at the devil then now he won't
have a problem killing a low life like
him and while the devil screams in agony
denji finishes him off once and for all
by casting the muscle devil into
multiple pieces from a distance we see
the girl eating her udon and saying out
loud that dingy sure is a useful dog
coming out of the woods tired while
carrying the girl on his back dingy
responds with a wolf before falling and
collapsing the girl catches him once
again though and asks him if he's okay
denji thinks to himself that she smells
good and apologizes to her for falling
as he accidentally ended up cutting
himself with a chainsaws and because of
that he continued to lose blood until he
fell
she asks did she how did his body even
end up like this to which he responds
that his pet devil pochita had become
his heart as he continues explaining his
disbelief and being alive the girl tells
him that historically speaking his
condition is extremely rare it's so rare
that it hasn't even been given a name
nor confirmed but she still says that
she believes him because she has an
especially good nose which is able to
tell that his best friend is still alive
inside of him and that his body also has
two sins one of a human and one of a
devil
as he hears this then she then blushes
and his stomach starts to gurgle again
reminding him that he wants to eat that
udon the girl then asks him if he can
feed himself to which dingy responds by
saying that he can however he stops
midway and realizes that he cannots
as the girl feeds and overjoyed dingy he
responds to her in ore by literally
barking like a puppy she then looks at
denji somewhat in disbelief that he can
actually enjoy a soggy udon as if he's
really like a dog then she blushes a
little and asks the girl what her name
is to which she responds that her name
is makima visibly taken back at the
beauty of your name dingy asks what kind
of guy she's into makima thinks for a
moment and answers telling him that it's
people just like him then she thinks to
himself for a moment somewhat confused
and then says isn't that me
while dingy thinks back on what makima
had just said he turns to her and goes
to say that he likes her as well but
then realizes she isn't there however
makima calls him over and it is shown to
him that she has taken him to the devil
hunters tokyo headquarters it has
explained through her that there are
over 1 000 devil hunters in tokyo alone
and that her bureau offers the best
staff but denji only thinks of what she
said earlier and starts imagining his
future with her makima gives denji a
uniform telling him that they normally
work in one and after he changes she
would introduce him to his colleague
after getting changed makima introduces
him to aki hayakawa saying that starting
today they are both partners then she
starts to complain hinting that he wants
to work with makima but before he can
say anymore aki drags him off while this
happens though makima walks up and tells
him that if he does well then they will
be able to work together while
patrolling the streets aki tells denji
to follow him for a moment once making
it to the end of an alleyway aki beats
him up punching him in the face and
kneeing him in the stomach afterwards
while lighting his smoke he tells him to
quit the devil hunter's bureau he
explains that people who became devil
hunters for weak reasons are the first
to die
saying that only the devil hunter is
still alive that he's worked with are
the ones with conviction he instantly
guesses correctly that denji only became
a devil hunter as he's interested in
makima as he finishes his smoke aki
throws it onto genji's chest and then
proceeds to spit on it to put it out
he then turns and says that he will tell
makima that denji got scared and
fearfully run away however dinji instead
hits him between their legs taking him
by surprise as he hits aki he explains
that today was the first day he felt
like a human and it was the first time
someone had treated him to a meal in his
entire life he tells him that if being a
devil hunter for those reasons is
shallow then he'll die to keep things
the way they are right now aki stands up
and fights back tackling denji and
continuing to punch him but as he threw
another punch he was once again hit
between the legs enraged then she
screams at him asking if it's because he
also likes her
though aki was unable to reply and
collapses onto the floor stating that he
really did only aim for the balls
returning to the headquarters dingy says
that aki got attacked by a testicle
devil but aki reveals that that was a
lie makima asks them if they'll get
along with both of them giving differing
answers but makima decides to put them
in aki's experimental squad either way
aki tries to say that he doesn't need
another weirdo as his team has already
filled with them but makima tells him
that his squad was meant to be
experimental which leaves aki confused
wondering what dingy is maki then
explains that denji can turn into a
devil and stunned aki says that cases
like them are just myths but she says
that he is a special type and if he
should ever run or quit then he will be
put down as a devil not understanding
the situation completely still then she
asks what she means and makima tells him
that it means that they will all be
working together until death do them
part
after leaving with aki denji asks if
makima is a good or a bad person in
hearing this aki tells him to be
grateful that at least he is still alive
but as he still insists on this question
aki tells him that she definitely is a
good person as he owes her his life
as he says this then she remembers how
she hugged him then cheekily remarks on
the melons that she carries around with
her which aki instantly perks up at
later on denji and aki start to live
together and the dream of the legendary
bread slice was completed but aki gets
annoyed after seeing the mess that dingy
leaves around the house and the amount
of times that he had to use the bathroom
pushing him almost to the breaking point
before erupting though aki receives a
call as there is an appearance of a
fiend in the eastner meda residence
after arriving at the location they head
towards the room to where they fiend
while heading there denji asks what a
fein is and aki explains that a fein is
a devil that has taken over a deceased
body of a person and are easily
identified by their heads as they see it
he explains more that things take on the
hosting devil's personality aki commands
denji to kill the fein and show his
devil power to prove himself however
then she decapitates and kills the devil
with a simple garden axe before aki
finished his sentence he goes on to say
to a confused aki that if he used his
power it would be a little overboard and
he wanted to give a painless death to
the faint archi gets angry and explains
that things may be half devils but they
are still devils and he shouldn't
sympathise with them as they don't have
feelings like humans intensely aki tells
him that a devil killed his entire
family right before his eyes and those
cops downstairs are his amaze and they
risk their lives every single day for
their wives and children
everyone around them is serious but
dingy is not aki says that he wants to
kill devils in the most suffering way
possible and questions then she's morals
when it comes to befriending devils to
which then she says that if there are
any devils that could be his friends
then he'll take them as he never had any
before however not impressed at his
answer aki tells him that he will
remember that before leaving the room
as denji looked down he saw some of
those melon magazines and he then
reveals that in reality he didn't want
to use his chainsaws as they will spray
blood all over his collectible manga
he then thinks to himself that he can
now shower eat tasty food and see a
lovely lady almost every day as well
here's everything he ever wanted already
but feels like something is missing he
notes that aki's goal is revenge or
something then curiously wonders if
makima has a dream of hers as well and
while thinking of her he comments that
he wants to touch some of her melons
dingy then realizes what he thought to
be impossible is now possible with his
current life
while he thinks back on what aki said
then she believes that now he has found
a serious dream and that is to touch
some of those beautiful melons
now over at the headquarters aki tells
the delirious dingy to watch his mouth
before mahima informs him that she is
pairing him up with a new partner while
dwelling over this thought makima
explains to him that they pair their
agents up with new partners for
small-scale missions and patrols once
your friend does arrive though makima
goes to leave and warns him that she is
a fame
power then makes her entrance telling
all of the humans to cower before her as
she is called power
then she starts to wonder athens can be
devil hunters but as he sees her chest
he quickly accepts it and greets her as
he gets excited to work with her
walking through the streets we find
dingy and power are patrolling however
power's having a crisis and screaming
out that she is thirsting for blood she
smacks dingy on the head and tells her
to let her kill something then she
ignores her and instead goes on about
how his issue is how he is going to
touch some of those melons having
recalls what makima had told him that
since power is a fame her horns will
attract attention so they must patrol
places with little traffic and if they
run into other devil hunters or
policemen to show his public safety
badge to them
as denji thinks about his safety badge
he remembers making his speech to him
and power on how the fourth section is
an experimental squad and if it doesn't
produce results their powers might break
it up which would then result in their
deaths as they couldn't find any devils
power boasts it must be because of how
fearsome of a devil she used to be and
how devils run from her scent dingy then
realizes that they can't produce results
that way and blames arki for setting him
up with power
all of a sudden power suddenly snaps
forward at the smell of blood and starts
running excited for a fight she jumps
from the building and creates a hammer
with the blood coming from her wrist
below her a fellow devil hunter is seen
in a call telling the headquarters that
the scene is locked down and the
civilians have been evacuated power
suddenly flies down and crushes the sea
cucumber devil sending its remaining
pieces flying in every direction as she
stands up she starts laughing and
screaming for people to gaze upon her
glory
later on as makima arrives on the scene
she explains to them that it's an
obstruction of justice when a public
safety devil hunter kills a devil that a
civilian devil hunter had already
engaged with she scolds power and dingy
telling power that she needs to think
before she acts and dingy needs to
control her more makima mentions that
power may not be suitable to be a devil
hunter as she gets excited too easily
hearing there power gets scared and says
that dingy told her to kill the devil
dingy and power then start arguing with
power continuing to blame him and injury
stating that she is a liar machima then
tells them to be quiet and power
instantly freezes with dingy catching on
slowly after after getting their
attention makima says that she doesn't
care who was at fault but she just wants
to see big things from them later on
power sees a cat and tells denji that
she can only get along with them she
hates humans off instinct because she
used to be a devil but she also explains
that she hates devils because they
kidnapped her pet cat meowi she
continues explaining then makima caught
her before she managed to save her care
and that it may have already been killed
but she would still do anything to get
her cat back she believes that denji
can't comprehend the feeling she has
towards her friend however denji states
he doesn't care about cats but mentions
that he will do anything to touch some
voluptuous melons
after power hears this she asks denji
hypothetically that if he retrieved
meowi from the devil for her she would
let him touch her melons initially
surprised at the idea then she
immediately changes his attitude towards
her and gets angry at the devil that he
had kidnapped a poor and innocent kitty
he states that it is unforgivable and as
a devil hunter he will not allow it to
continue and because of this he will
murder that damn devil
after receiving approval from the hq for
day leave it's revealed that power can't
go out on her own and instead always
needs a partner power says that she
knows where they could find the devil
but only denji would be able to fight
him because if the devil sees her it
would immediately use her pet as a
shield hearing this then she mentions
the power that he used to have a pet
devil and that he now lives inside of
him but power finds that idea foolish
and says that it just means pochita is
dead and saying he lives inside your
heart is just their pathetic attempt at
consolation while the two of them sit
there dingy thinks that there is no way
that either of them are ever going to
get along
meanwhile makima meets with the
higher-ups who inform her of the rumors
of the other nations using devils for
military purposes and hope that devils
remain the only enemy for japan and the
future they ask her about her dog squad
and she mentions that she has a
promising one and an interesting one
that she picked out recently before she
leaves though she is reminded by them
that she must not get attached as your
job is just to train the dogs and use
them
back in the car aki asks makima why she
is so interested in denji and she
explains the devils are born with a name
and the more scary the mental image you
have of it the more powerful they become
or the more powerful they are a coffee
devil would be weak as it doesn't have a
scary coronation but a car devil instead
would be strong as the image of getting
run over and dying terrifies people she
reveals that dingy can turn into the
chainsaw devil aki believes that that is
interesting but nothing more and
explains that he doesn't have any strong
enough conviction instead he just wants
to live through life idly plus on top of
that he thinks he can get along with
devils pretty much stating in arki's
eyes that he isn't fit for public safety
elsewhere power and dingy arrive at a
distant house on a small hill as they
get closer to the house then she brings
up how she must hide from the bat devil
in power not completely paying attention
slips up asking him if that was the
sitting and they confused the mana
because of this dingy realized that
something was not quite right and
attempts to hit power with his axe while
power created a blood hammer however
dingy isn't fast enough and power
manages to avoid his attack and then
hits him on the head knocking him
unconscious
power then drags denji inside the house
explaining to the devil inside that it
took her a while to get outside as she
couldn't move freely she then gives deji
to the bat devil as per their agreement
the bat devil takes dingy lifting him up
and showing the now awake denji his
missing arm stating that humans injured
him and made him hide but now he will
use this human's blood to heal he then
squeezes dingy like a towel and drinks
his blood regenerating his right hand
but once he drops dingy he complains of
how bad the taste of his blood was and
that he now needs to eat another human
to get rid of this bad taste inside of
the house power tells denji that humans
rarely are foolish for believing her
story outside of the house now and on
the roof the devil smells the medicine
cigarettes and makeup on humans and
decides to go and eat children as they
smell the nicest which is freaking weird
man inside of the house below him though
power reminds the devil of the deal and
requests meowi back but sadly as
punishment for bringing disgusting blood
the bat devil grabs maoi and places him
onto his mouth deciding to swallow him
as the bat devil swallows meowing power
falls into a flashback and remembers how
she met meowi and named the cat when she
found it it looked skinny but still
tasty so power decided to fatten it up
before she ate it and gave her cow milk
to grow nice and big
in time maui and power started to get
attached to each other making power feel
strange as she otherwise had killed
everything that she had met while lying
there on the roof of a random house
sadly the injured bat devil then
appeared and took meowi he told power to
bring him blood or else he would kill
meowi
seeing meowi etan powell turns to denji
and tells him that she now knows how
awful it feels not being able to pat
your pet as he can't pet pochita anymore
the bat devil then picks her up and
throws her into his mouth swallowing her
as well
as he notes her disgusting taste he
decides to go and eat some children to
rinse out his mouth while the devil
flies towards the city with he thought
that he will be eating he notices that
denji is clinging onto his leg and
drinking his blood and telling him to
give him his melons back the bat devil
once again crushes dengi's body in his
palm but this time dingy manages to tear
the kill switch on his chest in this
moment denji recalls how he lost pochita
in the past and they thought that he may
have been eaten by a devil but once he
had found him he was relieved and fell
asleep right on the spot as they crushed
denji hangs there in the hand of the bat
he wonders more about how power felt the
night maoi was taken by the devil and as
his thoughts continue to race his
chainsaws start protruding from his
forehead as he turns into the demonic
force of the chainsaw devil and starts
cutting into the devil's arm that had
literally just healed dingy chases the
bat devil through the air slashing at
him completely decapitating the devil's
right wing which sends the two of them
crashing through a building as denji
begins to get up inside of the destroyed
building he notices a young female
bystander and yells at her to run away
before she gets eaten after the girl
runs away an angered bat devil asks why
dingy would let a human get away when he
is also a devil
however not answering this question and
after standing up dingy immediately
sends himself flying through the room
while replying that it was so he could
split his belly and touch those melons
he slams and punches the devil's face
launching it through a brick wall and
out into the middle of a busy street as
denshi follows him outside the bat devil
asks aloud if he could cut through this
then proceeds to throw a nearby car at
dingy as the car flies towards the
chainsaw man he stands still not knowing
how to stop the heavy vehicle suddenly
though as he goes to stop the car with
his chainsaws he discovers that he is
able to retract the chainsaws on his arm
and because of this he successfully
catches the car as the devil admires
dingy's strength he asks aloud why would
you use that strength to save humans but
dingy replies that he couldn't care less
about some guy's stupid life and
immediately throws the car back at the
bat devil slamming it into his face
causing the entire rear of the car to
explode the bat devil though instantly
in retaliation after being hit uses a
sona-like ability that seemingly mangles
dengi's body and destroys the
surrounding buildings behind him as the
rubble falls the bat devil picks up the
helpless driver of one of the previous
vehicles in an attempt to eat and devour
him however the dust cloud suddenly gets
blown away revealing the mangled body of
the chainsaw man twisting and whipping
back together as danju takes out his
chainsaws once more he screams in rage
that's still even now after being
patient he still hasn't even touched a
singular melon not even once seeing the
rage seeping out of dingy the bat devil
yells at him to stay away however as he
tries to swing at dingy the devil gets
completely outclassed having his head
arm and stomach all cut open or off in
an instant leaving the bat to fall to
the ground completely and utterly dead
inside of the bat devil during a
flashback power recalls how she was
living freely with meowi and eating
animals like cows or beers but then it
all changed when the bat devil showed up
and stole meowi he told her to bring him
a human if she wants the cat to live
flashing forward initially while running
power thought that all lives are trivial
it was merely a cat but then she
wondered why am i running why am i even
searching for a human to save meowie she
then trips and slams onto the concrete
road causing her to think that it was
just a foolish reason
she sits up and realizes that she loves
blood the taste the smell feeling death
and then for the first time recalls
she loves the warmth of the blood and
meowi
in reality with tears in her eyes power
then awakens to see meowi who along with
power has been freed from inside of the
bat devil's guts by a now untransformed
dingy confused and half awake she then
asks dingy why he saved her even after
she tried to kill him however a mute
dingy only responds by doing his famous
chest point and melon squeeze hint at
which she remarks that that is a foolish
reason but as she apologizes for
deceiving him she still states that she
will allow him to touch her chest since
meowi had survived as dingy tries to
unfreeze his brain he realizes what she
had just said and starts celebrating but
within a second of his first bumping his
arm is suddenly cut off leaving dingy to
scream in pain as a horrid leech devil
picks up his severed hand in front of
him dingy asks if power can move but she
cannot she tells him to take me away and
run hearing this though denji decides to
fight the devil he rips on his kill
switch but as his body begins to
transform the sword becomes half stuck
in his head and it is revealed through
him that this state is due to a lack of
blood the leech devil is angry that
denji had killed her boyfriend the bat
devil but upon taking a closer look at
him she sees that denji is cute and
therefore will allow him to live but
will still kill power and meowi as he
hears this though dingy spits the blood
from his mouth and prepares to fight the
leech devil he jumps into the sky still
one-handed and swings the stump towards
the face of the devil immediately though
the leech devil slices dingy multiple
times leaving power stunned at how he is
actually fighting a devil in this date
just to touch some melons then she
manages to block a blow and punch the
leech in its face however he gets thrown
to the floor straight afterwards which
prompts the leech to question whether
the bat devil had really been beaten by
such a weak person the leech devil says
that the bear and her had dreamed of
eating humans together admitting that it
is an impossible but sublime and
beautiful dream he continues saying that
it is a shame that a cute face like this
is going to die
as he walks forward though denji
responds confidently that he will not
die before he cops a field to which the
leech devil responds that that is a
stupid idea and that he won't die to
someone with such a sleazy desire this
leads to denji getting angry as he
thinks about how everyone thinks his
reasonings are foolish and in an attempt
to do damage he lunges at the devil
slicing his face partly with his
chainsaw thinking that everyone looks
down on him for the stuff he does he
challenges their leech to a dream battle
he tells him that if he rips him apart
then that makes his dream worth less
than touching some melons the leech
devil accepts this challenge and he both
of them go to attack with the devil
telling him to beat him if he can then
she tries to get in close and has his
other remaining arm broken still though
he persists he just barely manages to
evade a strike to the face before he
leaps into the sky and sinks this small
section of his chainsaw he is out into
the skull of the leech devil however as
he rips the blade out it is revealed
that the leech devil had stabbed denji
through the torso he goes on to lift the
young hunter up to swallow him while
thanking him for the meal when suddenly
aki hayakawa shows up using his fingers
to summon his utterly insane yet
eye-catching and god damn dope fox devil
which bites the leech's head capturing
it then on aki's orders he eats it and
devours it killing the devil the other
newbies of the fourth squad also arrive
with arki and were then ordered to aid
and evacuate the survivors whilst hamino
a senior to aki is tasked to keep watch
for other devils as denji is picked up
by aki he is told that him and power are
to be taken for a debriefing whilst
meowi is to be taken to a veterinarian
hospital free fall check up dingy wakes
up in a hospital bed and sees aki
peeling an apple he tells him that they
found his arm and that it reattached
itself when he got a blood transfusion
also commenting that denji is really
like a devil then she responds to this
by telling him that he was talking with
a devil himself though aki explains that
this is how devil hunters fight by
making contracts with devils aki states
that he has a contract with a fox devil
he exchanges a part of his body for the
fox's power this time he let the fox
feed on part of its skin for killing the
leech devil aki says their devils always
desire the death of humans and the same
goes for fiends dingy responds though by
stating that power is a good theme
however aki catches denji and they lie
and states that they caught power and
dingy leaving the patrol area and that
they also found dingy's blood and what
they presume to be the bat devil's
hiding place he asks him why he still
sympathizes even after she tried to kill
him during the mini battle over the
apple slices aki tells dingy that if you
further investigated the incident he
would get dingy and power put down but
since there were no casualties aki
states that he would overlook the entire
incident on one condition that dingy
obeys aki's commands from now on he
continues telling him that he's a dumb
kid with no morals and he's been doing
this for much longer than he has so he'd
like to think that he stands for some
sort of social justice so just do as he
says and then you will be able to
protect the standard of life that he
currently has now after a short pause
dingy agrees to this telling him not to
worry as he doesn't have any grand goal
but he will take things just as
seriously as aki does so he can count on
him big time
aki then bows and leaves the room asking
denji to learn to speak with some kind
of respect to which then she says that
he will consider outside of the room
power stands there and handcuffs with
himino by her side power states that she
is innocent and demands to be let go not
sure if this is the right thing to do
hamino asks if it is a wise idea to free
her since if she kills anyone it would
be on aki but as hayakawa frees her he
says that they are devil hunters and
should make use of all the tools at
their disposal though he enforces that
enemies are enemies and they are only
using them with no intention whatsoever
of ever being friendly with one later on
as time flies forward power is seen
entering aki and denji's apartment no
team the cramped place that they have
stunned aki calls mahima asking why and
she responds by saying that she trusts
him more than anyone causing aki to
blush and agree mahima tells him that
power said she would be good so it'll be
fine however instantly after the call
ends power is seen to be visibly
disgusted by the vegetables in her food
because of this she throws them across
the room and both denshi and aki shout
at her for throwing the vegetables away
telling her that it is extremely
disrespectful
disrespectful to the farmers who grew
them
after eating power states that she's the
type who seldom bathes and seldom
flushes turds she laughs at them for
being so sensitive wondering what the
big deal even is
later in the day we find an anger dingy
who has to clean the toilet himself due
to power
power then enters the toilet and tells
the angry denji that she will now allow
him to touch her chest as they had a
deal and she intends to honor it
as denji looks down on power who's
sitting atop the toilet she asks him
what is he waiting for and to touch away
which causes denji to have a complete
and utter change in emotions calling
power and angel
while dingy shakes power tells dingy
that he gets three squeezes one for
saving meowi one for killing the bat and
third for protecting her from top knot
she reveals that originally she would
have allowed him to touch her melons but
because of what had just happened she
has changed her mind in an effort to
repay his efforts dingy makes his first
squeeze which makes power blush but
weirdly then she feels that something
just isn't right and he sees something
fall onto the ground below her power
picks them up and explains that those
are her melon pads which make her
overall chest size larger then she is a
bit shocked at the idea but proceeds
either way with a second and then final
squeeze
and as power celebrates that it is over
dengue is left standing there speechless
he thinks to himself that there's so
many things he wants to say but overall
it all just fell flat being square now
power tells denji that he is lucky to
touch something so nice and that she
looks forward to working with him in the
future however she continues saying that
she no longer needs to be a devil hunter
as meowi is safe but as she can't escape
makima she will do him a favor and help
him with his jobs once she leaves for
bed denji stands there feeling
disappointed and empty later on he does
paperwork with makima who notices that
something is wrong with him he reveals
to her that he finally accomplished a
dream of his that he had been chasing
for a long time but once he finally had
it in his hands it just felt
disappointing dingy now wonders if it
will feel disappointing too for other
dreams he will accomplish and if he
would be happier chasing dreams instead
of achieving them mahima asks directly
what he is talking about and then she
reveals that the first set of melons he
ever touched turned out to be no big
deal which had fallen completely flat of
his expectations for a moment makima
looks at him then she takes his hand and
explains that she believes naughty
things feel better the more you know
your partner as she explains this she
touches his hand saying
it's difficult to understand another's
heart so first take your time studying
her hands her fingers she grabs his hand
and places it on her ear continuing and
saying
how are her ears shaped as she bites his
finger she asks if he had ever had it
bitten before she then tells him to
memorize just how it feels know it so
well that even if you lost your side you
would recognize her by bite she then
grabs his hand and places it on her
melon which makes denji blush and fall
back in his chair crashing to the floor
makima gets close to him so close that
they almost make contact and she asks
him for a favour makima sits back in
danger's chair and asks him to defeat
the gun devil
while a confused denji stands there she
explains that the gun devil appeared 13
years ago and his location is currently
unknown
he is a powerful devil that all the
devil hunters are anxious to kill but
she believes denji is special and would
be able to do it
mahima then tells denji that if he kills
the gun devil then she will grant him
any one wish whatever it be that he
desires
dingy sitting there on the floor
completely shocked by making his offer
to grant him any wish stunned he insists
to make sure she isn't tripping when
makima cuts him off telling denji that
the devil is so strong and evil that it
is okay to offer him a completely blank
check she continues on explaining that
13 years ago the world was different as
they tried to use guns to counter devils
however due to an excess use of guns and
firearms both in devil hunting and in
the wider world with robberies and
murder fare over weapons began to build
and on the day of a major terrorist
incident in the usa the gun devil
suddenly appeared as we flow 13 years
back in time to a flashback with a young
boy who's reading with his parents we
find his older brother standing there in
the doorway asking to play catch with
their father in the snow but he tells
him that his younger brother isn't
feeling well and will have to do
something by himself which aggravates
the young boy as he says that his father
always says that they begin to argue but
tayo the younger brother says that he
would like to play with his older
brother as they step outside their
parents tell them to come back if they
get cold and once out the older brother
demands that tayo stop following him as
he is annoying however as he goes to
throw a snowball at his brother taiyo
launches one at him first and hits him
square in the face afterwards he knows
how cold his hands are and his brother
tells him to go grab his gloves from
inside the house so that they don't get
colder the younger brother runs off
happily towards the house and as tayo
re-enters sadly and seemingly in an
instant both he and the belding are
obliterated by the gun devil's blast it
is explained that on november the 18th
1984 at 10 am the gun devil hit japan
for 26 seconds and completely
obliterated a total of fifty seven
thousand nine hundred and twelve men
women and children elsewhere throughout
the world the death was unparalleled
with the us alone having over five
hundred thousand deaths and china
another three hundred thousand when the
total numbers were finally calculated it
was revealed that in about five minutes
the gun devil had almost killed 1.2
million people around the globe then
completely disappeared and has never
been seen since back in the present
mahima explains that the gun devil has
been missing since leading to a banning
on all firearms globally as well as an
increase in the power of all devils due
to the heightened climate of fear trying
to take all this news in denji admits he
struggled to follow along to him a story
and that the devil sounds too strong to
even comprehend but even so he still
confidently declares that he'll beat the
gun devil if he tries super duper hard
then she then asks her how exactly he is
going to find this thing to which makima
shows him that small chunks of the gun
devil's body were left as residue after
its attack as it moved so fast that its
body burned parts off she says that when
any devil eats these pieces their powers
are enhanced but if you put these pieces
together they begin attaching
apparently the gun devil is so strong
that when the pieces of its flesh
combine to a certain size they'll try to
return to its body and regenerate so
pretty much if they just continue to
chunk more bits together they'll
eventually be able to locate the gun
devil we then skip over to aki and
hirmino who were recovering a piece of
the gun devil that had been eaten by a
small fried devil as the two chair about
the meaning of their mission it is
revealed that the older brother and the
flashback was indeed aki hayakawa now on
his next mission denji alongside several
other hunters such as power aki and
himeno are instructed to hunt a powerful
devil who had already killed many
civilian devil hunters that had
attempted to exterminate it aki states
that there has been movement from a gun
devil peace so it is likely that a devil
has ingested another part of it the
group approaches the hotel dingy and
power begin verbally harassing aki but
are quietened when he offers them both a
gum for their silence araya expresses a
distrust over denji and power's presence
however aki reassures him that they're
merely there to aid and slain the devil
and if either of them step out of line
they'll be killed
power and dingy begin bickering saying
that the reason he's so annoyed must
have been because of the prank that they
played on him earlier in the day
overhearing them aki explodes in anger
telling them that the prank went way too
far surprised at his outburst himenu
tells him that he can't be strict with
him all the time with danji agreeing so
in order to ease the tension she
promises to give whomever kills the
devil a kiss on the cheek aria is
shocked that a young woman like himino
would give herself away before marriage
and denji also refuses her claiming that
he has already decided who his first
kiss is going to be first though he is
simply going to collect these meat
chunks and then kill the gun devil argue
responds intensely wondering if he
really could kill the gun devil and
tamino says that that was pretty ballsy
to say in front of aki
then she also brings up that naughty
stuff feels best the more you know your
partner and he doesn't even know her
name yet himenu playfully rebuffs him
promising him a french kiss if he kills
the devil to which denji reacts
excitedly panting like a dog further in
the hotel their group moves through the
corridors as denji and durai begin
arguing arai manages to pin denji to the
wall in an attempt to stop him from
reaching the devil first saying that he
won't let some punk steal her lips while
this happens aki and himino discuss the
other members of the team himino says
that arai has a strong drive but lacks
power whereas kabini is the opposite
she's timid but strong aki says the
blood thing is also strong but it's
possible she'll still betray them
however when it comes to dingy he still
doesn't know what his potential truly is
ximena asks if he thinks that the
newbies will be able to survive but he
instead just gives her a vague response
about how they may end up dead or at the
civilian sector soon enough hearing her
question get dodged himeno instead
orders aki not to die
which is we find instantly after in a
flashback where the two first meet it's
revealed that aki is himino's sixth
partner and all of her other ones had
died because they were useless no bodies
but one of the first things she ever
said to him was to not die back in the
present himeno senses a nearby presence
and tells aki that it is approaching
them a room door then opens and a small
demon made up of only a head one hand
and a foot runs out in front of them
the small fleshy creature leaps at
kabini but is locked in place by hamino
and the power of the ghost devil power
then cheekily slices the creature in
half saying that the damn devil froze in
media out of fear of her but hermino
explains that her power was actually the
real reason similar to aki she gave her
right eye in order to use the ghost
devil's invisible right hand aki then
confirms that the devil they just slayed
wasn't the one and the group continues
upstairs as they walk power playfully
threatens them saying they shouldn't
blabber about their powers in front of
her but hermino says it'll be easier to
work as a team if they know each other's
powers plus she has a trump card either
way power then points her blood blade at
this scared girl only for himino to
cheerfully grab her throat with a ghost
devil commanding the fiend to put the
weapon away which she does as the group
reaches the top of the stairs orion
notices that despite moving towards the
9th floor the sign shows them still
being on the 8th running downstairs to
check arise suddenly appears at the top
of the staircase the group tests the
theory with aki moving through rooms and
discovering that they are concurrents
the group concludes that they are
trapped on the eighth floor somehow and
aki breaks down the situation so that
they all understand no matter what they
do they cannot escape every single exit
they try to use results with them ending
back in the same location which is
likely due to the handiwork of a devil
hearing this dingy remarks that it's
power's fault as he bets the devil she
apparently killed trapped them there
upon its death however aki states that a
devil's powers are undone when they die
so that would be impossible as their
group comes to the realization that
they've walked into a trap awry brings
up how other devil hunters will come and
rescue them after hq doesn't hear back
for a few hours because of this kabini
begins to panic though and goes on about
how she never wanted to join the devil
hunters and would have rather gone to
college instead while confronting
cabinet hemino notices a puzzled look on
aki's face he notes that all the clocks
in the room have stopped at 8 18
theorising that the floor is trapped in
time making the rescue impossible
everyone is left shocked by the news
apart from denji who instead is
delighted by the lack of time
constraints choosing to take a nap iry
berates him but then she shrugs it off
and instead tells them to wake him when
they figure it out he then calmly falls
asleep much to the shock of the group
himino reawakens denji and informs him
that they are still stark while he was
asleep they found out that the power and
water still works but when it comes to
food they have an extremely limited
supply aki has continued to hunt for the
devil arai has grown restless and closed
himself away in the covers and cabinet
was forcibly knocked out after
attempting to drink water from the
toilet when it comes to the feign ximena
presumes power is equally unhinged
however denji notes that she always acts
bizarrely was the trio guard the room
for orion cabinet ximena explains that
it's great to have an addiction as
you'll need something in life to take
the edge off then she notices the smoke
she has and says it's the same brand
that aki smokes to which hermina reveals
that she gave him an appreciation for
cigarettes as we go into a flashback we
find a younger aki and himino discussing
the reason he became a public safety
devil hunter himeno guesses correctly
that it's because of the gun devil and
states that devil hunters don't live
long anyway so it's not like smoking is
gonna kill ya aki states though that he
won't bite it so easily to which she
replies that he better not as it's a
hassle when her buddies die
as the peer walk outside himino is
approached by a woman who suddenly slaps
her after the woman leaves hemino
discloses that she was her previous
buddy's girlfriend she says she has come
to expect such abuse as a way for the
grieving families to vent their
frustration
however not happy at this archaean
retaliation sticks gum on the girl's
clothes as he tries to justify why
himino bursts out laughing later on at a
nearby diner emino tells aki that he
reminds her of something her master
always says the devil hunters that the
devils fear the most aren't the
strongest or they're brave they're
afraid of the ones but they few screws
loose and she thinks that he'll live for
a long while because of this she manages
to manipulate aki into picking up a
smoke which over time has become a
symbol of their friendship in the
present aki returns asking himino if she
has any smokes left to which she states
that this is her last one as the two
addicts share in the butt of a smoke
then she pipes up saying that that was
an indirect kiss to which he is told to
shut up as aki reveals that he has
discovered the devil that they have been
searching for he reminds them of the
devil power had just killed however now
rather than just a small humanist shape
it took before it is multiplied into a
large and imposing wall of flesh outside
of the room the devil mocks the group
before offering them an extremely
enticing contract let me eat the human
name denji dead or alive feed him to me
and if they follow the contract rules
they will be returned unharmed suddenly
the door opens with cabinet walking out
holding their knife and demanding that
denji lets the massive pile of flesh eat
him aki and himino immediately subdue
kabini kicking the knife out of her hand
and whacking her to the floor hemino
tells aki to summon his fox but it is
unsuccessful due to the severed link
with the outside world himeno uses a
ghost to attack the devil which inflicts
pain however it grows in size with each
attack enveloping more of the hallway
and grabbing at her the devil says that
it is no use as its weak point is not on
the eighth floor and that this is
actually the inside of its stomach so
making a contract with him is the only
way to escape emino explains that a
devil's contract is unbreakable meaning
that if a devil did not fulfill its end
deal it would die as such allowing denji
to die would guarantee the other safety
hearing this arrivos that they let denji
be consumed aki refuses though he argues
that the devil likely has an ulterior
motive behind specifically denji's death
to which himino agrees as well power
casually votes to kill denchi only for
aki to explain that as a fiend she is
exempt from contracts and as such could
be still killed by the devil power
scoffs before cheerily asking and an
annoyed denji if he wants to wrestle the
group weight in the corridor nearby the
approaching wall of flesh pondering the
issue of starvation aki offers to use
the sword however hamina refuses his
suggestion
as urai returns to their room he
discovers power has eaten all of their
food even still she attempts to blame
denji kabini then appears and in a
paranoid delusional state accuses power
of being the one trapping them as a riot
attempts to calm her down she accuses
him of siding with the fame and working
with the devils he tries to deny her but
she still attacks him as awry begins to
scream out of fear the devil in the
hallway suddenly grows lunging at the
three still in the corridor the devil
chases them through the eighth floor
revealing that it grows in size based on
fear and that he the eternity devil will
be the one to kill the chainsaw devil
suddenly their rooms begin tilting as it
forces everyone to the opening of its
mouth demanding they give him dengue's
heart as the eternity devil looms
towards the group cabani and awry demand
they feed denji to it but aki instead
insists that he'll use the sword to get
them out however himino binds him
explaining that using such a weapon will
massively shorten his lifespan
araya and kabini lungit denshi however
as the girl goes to stab him aki jumps
in the way and blocks them getting
stabbed instead he explains that though
he doesn't like dingy he needs all the
allies he can get to help him defeat the
gun devil and so he's willing to
sacrifice his own well-being in order to
protect denji
shocked dingy asks power if she can stop
the bleeding to what she does otherwise
she won't have a human cook seeing aki's
injured state and a vision of her former
partner's graves himeno collapses not
knowing what to do and suffering a
complete breakdown kabini tries blaming
denji for the situation they are
currently in and frustrated as well then
she accepts his fate of being eaten but
informs the group he doesn't plan on
going down without a fight and if he
kills the devil he still wants his kiss
they wonder if he has a strategy but
dingy have he noticed the devil
screaming in pain as amino attacked it
earlier realises that though the
creature is invulnerable it still feels
pain
therefore then she plans to injure the
creature to the point of literally
making it kill itself the entire group
is left shocked by his devilish way of
thinking but as he leaps into the mouth
of the devil tearing his kill switch
dingy comments on aki's full heartiness
and remarks that if they escape because
of this then both of them are now even
with a smile on his face dingy drops
into the sinkhole of flesh and for a
brief moment the devil fully swallows
denji making it seem as though he simply
died before he shatters the teeth
holding him inside its mouth then
exploding from the face of the eternity
devil in his complete chainsaw form he
begins slicing into the devil he begins
slicing into the devil and as the others
look on in horror at his transformation
the devil manages to break one of
dingy's arms but he immediately rips his
kill switch again restarting the
chainsaws and tearing into more of the
devil from above power comments on the
danger that denji is currently in
because he is losing blood fast his time
only chainsaw form is reduced however
with even the devil screaming in him
saying he was weaker than he once was
dingy still doesn't slow down the
eternity devil continues biting into
denji resulting in denji losing enough
blood to retract his chains or arms the
devil begins laughing telling him to die
until it is interrupted by dingy biting
it back and regaining his chainsaws
while fighting the devil dingy tells it
that even blood as gross as sewer water
would taste like strawberry jam if he
drank it while looking at him as himeno
looks on she has a flashback with an old
man in a graveyard in it the man
comments on how the best devil hunters
are those with a few screws loose and
the reason her past buddies have died
was because all of them were too sane
feeding the devils through their fear
the old man warns hamino of aki's
genuine intention to defeat the gun
devil and as he goes to leave he
recommends she train him as quickly as
possible for such an eventual fight
against the gun devil this entire
thought though left hemino troubled as
she didn't want to lose aki so she later
offers him a relaxed position in the
civilian sector but he flat out refused
her saying that he'll drink with her
whenever she wants but he'll never go to
the civilian sector
hemino pinches a smoke of him and while
sitting there sadly comes to the
realization that the gun devil would
certainly kill aki not because they are
unable to beat it but because aki is
cool
serious and kind he's normal like
everyone else
but just as she goes to finish her
sentence she has a moment of hesitation
in the present she's looking down on
denji who continues to tear into the
eternity devil moments later though he
collapses of exhaustion which causes the
devil to begin celebrating however
himino uses the ghost devil to pull
denji's cord reawakening him then she
suddenly realizes that by drinking the
blood of the eternity devil he can
quickly recover his wounds and stamina
meaning he can continue attacking
indefinitely which causes himino to
truly think that denji is damn crazy and
might actually be able to kill the gun
devil
three entire days later now exhausted
and weak jimeno climbs into bed next to
aki and asks him to go drinking but
first she's gonna take a nap as it is
finally over as aki lays there thinking
that it's over below them the eternally
devil lays in tattered pieces it reveals
its core to denchi begging him to hurry
up and kill it so its suffering can end
denji obliges commenting what it's
already over before slashing the devil
in half which dies with a smile on its
face finally relieved from its pain
later on the group emerges from the
hotel with denji bloodied and weary he
is super happy to have recovered a piece
of the gun devil but immediately
afterwards collapses from exhaustion
ximena catches him saying that her and
aki will take him to the hospital then
asking her in kabini to report the
events of the incident to makima
sometime later she suggests the group
all go drinking as they had stated
earlier in the hotel however aki reveals
kabini and arai are quitting the bureau
and suggests that the recent experience
was too dramatic for them
himeno argues though that it may be
instead due to the guilt over attacking
denchi and not because they are scared
of devils aki brings up that even himino
though tried to kill denji so eventually
they agreed to drink sometime later in
the week on the prerequisite that they
could apologize to dingy and because
makima is leaving on a work trip the
week after as they stand there smoking
ximena asks about makima's fascination
with dinghy saying that she normally
travels all over the place but lately
she's been hanging around didn't she and
wonders if it's because she knows her
secret but aki remains silent she then
changes the subject slightly asking if
they should get her drunk and try to get
the real answer out of her at the
restaurant we find the fourth division
or chatting happily one of the guys
tells denchi to order more food but he
is left frustrated as he can't read the
menu due to his illiteracy when suddenly
he's reminded of himino's promise to a
french kiss ximena tells him she'll do
it when she's more intoxicated saying
she feels too sober she goes on to say
that she'll make it an intense one for
him so please forgive the team for
trying to kill him during their mission
excited then she happily forgives the
others for trying to kill him the group
go around the table introducing
themselves most are shocked to hear
denji's young age of only 16 and a riot
introduces himself as well as a 22 year
old male who is contracted with the fox
devil aki explains that the fox devil is
friendly with humans and a lot of devil
hunters have contracts with it
fushi an older hunter casually reveals
that his partner had died the day before
frightening the other young hunters who
ask if recruits die that easily they are
told that they get all the devils that
their civilian hunters couldn't handle
so people in their line of work often
drop like flies himino now more drunk
makes flirtatious comments towards denji
and he suddenly grows more excited when
he learns that himeno often starts
kissing people when drunk
suddenly mahima arrives then she
immediately grows flustered and
uncertain as to whether he wants to kiss
himino or try and wait for makima then
she begins to panic desperately wanting
to kiss amino whilst not wanting to kiss
her in front of makima he tries to drive
the conversation in a different way
saying he found one of the gun pieces
aki interrupts wondering why devils with
gun pieces are appearing this frequently
and simply why the eternity devil
targeted denji he questions makima about
her interests in denji however after
finishing her first class she coolly
tells him that she'll tell them if they
can drink it out of her everyone
continues drinking until most have
passed out or left only makima seems
completely unaffected by the alcohol
asking for more instead over the other
side of the room power begins boasting
about her high iq but after she realizes
that it's a pretty normal one she
continuously lies and increases its
height and an effort to match the
ever-increasing smartness in the room
suddenly himino grabs denji from behind
and kisses him deeply danger is
concerned by makima watching but begins
to focus on the warmth in his mouth he
at first assumes a tamino's tongue
before moving back and realizing she had
vomited in his mouth the table all
reacted differently with power worriedly
stating that denji's childhood
malnourishments means he would swallow
anything for the nutrients instantly
just as she predicted dingy swallows the
vomit a flashback shows denchi and
pachita rummaging for food through a
dumpster they see a group of rats facing
on a pile of vomit to which dingy mocks
them not believing any creature could
stoop that low cutting back to the
restaurant awry comforts dingy in a
toilet cubicle as then she vomits into a
bowl noting the upset look on his face
he says that himeno needs more
self-control while he helps him ori
tells him how jealous he is of his devil
hunting abilities annoyed though then
she points out that he still has vomit
in his mouth from his first curse
questioning what exactly he's jealous of
causing a rye to chuckle
later on the group will leave the
restaurant makima asks where denji is
and fushi states that he left with
himeno on his back moments later in
another location then she awakens in a
bed asking for water i still intoxicated
himino appears and kisses him again
revealing that they are in her apartment
she complains to him asking what he and
aki see in mahima and calls her a [__]
as she lies down next to denshi she
leans in and asks him whether he wants
to do it with her
denji agrees to have that sekki time
with himino and she starts undressing
him however as she begins to take off
his pants she stops when she finds a
dirty lollipop in his pocket during the
time back at the restaurant while denchi
was in a demotivated mood after the
vomit kiss makima took him outside for
some fresh air and buys some various
medicines to help with his sickly
feeling upset then she comments on how
poor his first kiss was expressing a
worry that all future kisses will remind
him of the taste of bath
makima sucking on a cold lollipop though
offers it to him telling him he probably
won't be able to forget the taste of
vomit for the rest of his life but not
to worry as he is going to experience
all kinds of tastes from now on until he
dies for starters this will be his first
indirect kiss and that is the taste of a
cola flavoured chapat back in the
present denji holds the lollipop staring
at it while hamino has passed out behind
him then she apologizes to vegeta having
refused to sleep with himeno stating
that he wants to wait for miss mahima to
be his first
so until he kills the gun devil he will
wait ximena wakes him in the morning and
cheerily offers him breakfast
now out on the balcony ximena tells him
she doesn't remember anything from the
previous night and asks if she forced
herself on him denji informs her he
refused her advances as he's saving
himself for mahima and she expresses her
relief as she didn't want to get
arrested for sleeping with a minor she
asks whether dingy is serious about
liking mahima despite her poor
personality dingy reaffirms this by
stating that he likes crap and himino
happily offers to help the two get
together the two agree upon a top secret
alliance whereby she will aid him in
return for him helping her get with aki
then she curiously asks what she likes
about aki to what she says that it's his
looks and because of this a very sly
looking dingy says that he's in on the
alliance happy hamino tells denji that
they are now friends rather than
co-workers and invites him aki and power
to visit any time
meanwhile makima and another devil
hunter sit on a train 30 minutes outside
of kyoto the two of them talk about the
food they will buy when they arrive at
the station
afterwards as makima thinks of the night
before a group of passengers all around
them suddenly begin opening bags and
pulling out guns then proceeding to
shoot the two hunters until they are
obviously dead one of the assassins then
speaks repeating this is c team this is
c team commence operation
while in a ramen shop dingy himeno aki
and power all eat meanwhile various 4th
division agents from the previous
night's drinking attend to their duties
in various locations throughout the city
as they do all the civilians around them
pull out guns and gun shots are heard
ringing out the group inside the ramen
shop hears the gunshot but they assume
that they're merely drum beats a
stranger on the table next to them then
speaks up insulting the quality of the
ramen dingy and power are both offended
by this and the man comments on the
appears unrefined palette remarking that
those who do not eat much in the youth
gain a poor sense of taste sensing
something wrong aki asks to leave the
man continues though discussing his
beloved grandfather whom would often
spoil him he then reveals his
grandfather to be the old man who was
possessed by the zombie devil he accuses
denji of the old man's death before
stating the gun devil wants your heart
he pulls out a gun and shoots dingy in
the head before shooting hamino and the
chest and arky in the arm before he can
continue though power punches him
knocking the gun out of his hand aki
then summons the fox devil to devour the
man he then worriedly looks at dingy's
unmoving body as well as hamino's
critically injured state the fox devil
then suddenly informs him that the man
was neither human nor devil before it is
torn apart from the inside the man
re-emerges revealing himself to be a
devil human hybrid fused with the katana
devil aki orders power to stop hemino's
bleeding as he pulls out his sword aki
unleashes his sword and power is
surprised to see that it resembles a
nail rather than a blade katana man
starts swinging atom but aki dodges
before reading in his blade as he shouts
fire an off-panel devil is shown
flicking the nails point into the katana
man a disembodied mouth is then seen
sounding their number three
katana man hesitates before swinging
again aki once again dodges shouting
fire once more and piercing the katana
man again again the disembodied voice
speaks saying the number two
aki makes a final lunge piercing the
katana man's belly and the voice states
one
the katana man knocks aki back showing
confusion over aki's plan aki however
calls the devil out to finish him
revealing it to be the cursed devil as
the devil states zero a massive
disembodied hand is shown to grab the
katana man he briefly expresses shock
before being torn limb from limb by the
giant skeletal devil he falls to the
floor unconscious and bleeding profusely
aki calls out to power who recommends
getting hamino a doctor aki is shocked
by the use of a gun in the man's ominous
statement regarding the gun devil
suddenly a young woman appears
commenting on the cursed devil's power
as aki asks whether she's working with
the katana man she steps forward and
picks him back up the girl named
salwatari asks the katana man why he
lost to which he assumedly responds he
let down his guard
she orders him to kill the group quickly
leading the katana man to lunge forward
at aki before he can respond his chest
is suddenly slashed by the katanas aki
heavily injured by the attack falls to
the floor sawatari comments on how the
wounds are likely non-fatal due to the
devil hunter's suits being reinforced
himino tells power to forget her and
help aki however power refuses believing
herself to be far outmatched hemino
attempts to summon the ghost devil but
it refuses out of fear of sarwatari as a
last resort to save aki himuno offers
her everything to the ghost devil the
devil's grimace quickly turns to a smile
as its true giant form is revealed the
ghost devil attacks the katana man with
each attack himino loses more of her
body as she does this she thinks about
aki and remarks on how unusual it is
that he was still able to cry as most
devil hunters grow emotionally stunted
over time
as aki looks at her she tells him not to
die as she wants someone to be able to
cry over her death sawatari summons the
snake devil ordering it to devour the
ghost devil it does leaving nothing left
to firmino aside from her clothes
sawatari and the katana man turned to
denji stating that their goal is to take
his heart as they say this the ghost
devil's dying hand is seen floating
towards demji's body it pulls the cord
on his chest reawakening and
transforming him into his chainsaw form
though he is confused by the current
situation he instantly recognizes the
katana man and sawatari as enemies
excitedly charging at them stating that
he loves bad guys as no one cares how he
brutally kills them salwatari noting she
is missing fingernails calls for backup
over a walkie-talkie she looks at aki
who was in shock over himino's fate
denji and the katana man continue
fighting with the katana man showing the
ability to slash large areas with a
single strike two backup agents arrive
firing guns at denji though he is shot
he's able to knock both down and takes
one as a hostage angrily the katana man
slices through both of them cutting them
in half at a speed denji was unable to
register picking up dingy's top half the
katana man orders the other agents to
get to a car remarking that the other
members of the fourth division are
likely dead due to the human
vulnerability to guns the scene cut
showing the corpses of arai fushi hamino
makima and the two other hunters who
were at the drinking party in makima's
train carriage the assassins plan to
blend in with the civilians however they
are interrupted by makima standing up
who has somehow miraculously survived at
the station two hunters cross and tendo
wait they are shocked to hear news of
makima's death before seeing her step
out of the train in front of them makima
informs them of the attack as they
remark on these similar attacks in tokyo
they note their blood on her clothes but
she tells them that she was not hit
during the gun fight as she dodged every
bullet
inside the train we find the bodies of
the train assassins each of them with
gaping holes in their chests
moving forward mahima theorizes that the
gun agents are going after denji she
orders corrose nintendo to find her a
shrine with a high elevation and 30
criminals with life sentences as well as
a change of clothes
elsewhere the gun agents begin to move
dengue's top half into a car
as they do one begins to sweat remarking
how strange he feels in an instant he is
flattened by an invisible force
horrifying his compatriots panicked
sabatari calls the team e asking them to
confirm makima's death with c team and a
team agent responds commenting that
they've lost contact with sea team
however he is too flattened mid-sentence
elsewhere at the shrine makima enacts a
ritual tendo and kuros as well as 30
prisoners are blindfolded tendu informs
corrose that due to her high ranking the
nature of the devil magima has a
contract with is kept classified makima
orders a prisoner to say the name
mishima shuzo he complies the gun agent
named mishima shuzo is instantly
flattened afterwards the prisoner then
falls dead as makima instructs the next
prisoner to say another name and so on
and so on throughout the entire country
multiple gun agents are constantly
flattened suddenly mahima stops makima
instructs karos and tendo to take off
their blindfolds telling them that she
has done all she can do from their
current location
panicked to the situation and people
dying around her sawatari orders the
katana man to move denji before makima
can interfere further as he does he
suddenly sees a figure moving towards
them which is kabini clutching a knife a
flashback shows they whilst on duty
together arai was shot by an elderly gun
agent in his last moments he threw
himself in front of kabini shielding her
from being killed as well kavini asks
sawatari and the qatar man whether they
are gun agents and unnerved sabotage
summons the snake devil's tail to attack
her she swiftly dodges it though before
running along its body towards the pier
before the katana man could shoot at her
she deftly slices his arm off grabs the
gun and shoots him in the back she then
turns her aim to sabotari sabotari fires
at her but she uses dingies reinforced
chainsaw head to deflect the bullet
samutari grabs the katana man and drags
him into the car driving away kumini
looks down at denji's unconscious torso
and apologizes for trying to kill him in
the past she slowly begins to laugh
growing slowly hysterical as she
remembers a rise dead body before
deciding she plans to tell hermino that
she quits
at a similar time arriving in tokyo
makima is greeted by madoka he informs
her that almost every agent in divisions
one through four were killed he states
that the orders from the top of the
organizations and that all divisions
will be merged and placed under
machima's control the news causes her to
smile calmly madoka anticipating a
coming conflict quits on the spot as he
leaves he asks makima one more thing
how much of the events she had
anticipated but she merely responds that
she is unable to share classified
details with a civilian
awakening in a hospital bed aki turns to
see denji and power at his bedside
reading manga and arguing over apples
aki asks who of the fourth division
survived with dingy responding that only
kabini and madoka made it but madoka had
instantly quit dingy and power then
turned to leave as they were summoned by
makima however noting aki's quiet
despondence dingy leaves him an apple
now alone in his room aki and she's the
cursed sword and asks the cursed devil
how long he has to live
it responds that he is two years aki
then picks up a cigarette however
remembering hirmino he drops it and
breaks down crying outside the room then
she looks through the window hoping to
collect the manga that he had left in
there he begins to walk away before
suddenly realizing that despite his
attachment to himino her death has not
caused her to cry or feel any real
sadness he thinks back to the sadness he
felt after pochita's death and realizes
that neither power nor arki's death
would make him cry
he thinks that even if mahima were to
die though he would be depressed for a
short while he would get over it
surprisingly quick troubled by these
thoughts he wonders if giving his heart
to a devil truly robbed him of his
humanity resolving not to think about
such depressing topics he and power
leave to meet with makima as they do
tendo and carroz enter aki's room to
instruct him regarding the changes to
the fourth division meanwhile makima
explains the denji and power that the
bureau believes enemy forces are
targeting denji specifically as such
they have prepared a training course for
the two of them she begins to introduce
them to kishibe but is interrupted by
him he asks them of their thoughts when
their comrades died to which they state
that they pretty much felt nothing he
then asks them of their desire for
revenge which they both rebuff lastly he
asks them whether they're loyal to
humans or devils to which they both
respond whomever will give them the best
deal hearing this kishibe expresses a
satisfaction with their responses he
steps forward and puts his arms around
dingy and powell's shoulders stating
that their training has started makima
turns to leave eskashibe explains that
he is a devil hunter working with a
special first division and asks that
they call him master he then informs the
pair that he enjoys booze woman and
killing devils before he begins to
calmly choke the two of them then snap
their necks kashibe drops power and
dingy to the floor explaining that their
basic body structures are identical to
humans and as such he snapped their
necks paralyzing them he then gives them
blood explaining that unlike humans it
is all they need to recover from most of
the injuries kishibe explains that he is
the strongest devil hunter and as such
he believes that in order to train the
two of them they need to reach a point
where they can beat him in a
confrontation did you empower move
towards him preparing to fight however
kishibe swiftly stabs denji in the head
and back before slitting power's throat
he comments on the inhuman intuition to
try and attack him without a moment of
hesitation he states that since he was a
child he always hoped for a toy that
wouldn't break before promising to turn
the pier into the baddest of the
badasses
meanwhile in his hospital beard aki is
surprised to find he is unable to summon
khan caro's remarks that the devil is
likely angry for being killed and as
such likely to never respond to him
again
tendu asks of aki's lifespan after using
the cursed devil but he interrupts and
asks of their intentions with him they
reveal that due to the worsening of the
devil crisis and massive losses to the
organization the bureau intended to
request he makes a deal with a massively
powerful devil to help gain an advantage
they then give him the choice to quit
and live in a more peaceful life however
he refuses seeking revenge against the
gun devil for killing his family and the
gun agents for killing himino
as kuros and tendo leave an unseen woman
enters surprising haki that night
kishiba decides to stop the training so
that he can go home and sleep denji
collapses from exhaustion as power gives
him some of her blood to heal him the
pair walk home bloodied and tatted power
comments on how dingy likely died 20
times and she was knocked unconscious
the same amount the two consider running
away with zinji noting that fighting
without enjoying himself is the worst
suddenly power suggests that rather than
using brute force they try and outsmart
kishibe causing the pair to grow excited
and remark that they feel smarter
already kishibi walks towards denji and
power's apartment annoyed at them for
being late to training from inside power
smells his presence as the pair now
wearing glasses moved to put their super
genius strategy into action
power thrusts a spear of blood through
the door however kishibe intuitively
dodges it on the floor above the parrot
place bottles of blood which power uses
to spare through the ceiling above
kishibe again kishime blocks and dodges
them however denji drops down behind him
quietly hoping to hit him with an axe
however kishibe swiftly kicks him in the
head knocking him down without even
looking kishibe commenced them for their
attempt stating it was their best yet
but points out that the pair were
weakened by power's massive loss of
blood and dingy's inability to predict
attacks he tells them that they're done
for the day however as denji begins to
relax he flings a knife at him one in
the duo that pray shouldn't trust what a
hunter says
meanwhile kuros and tindo take aki to
the bureau's devil holding facility they
remind him that making a contract with
these devils will entail heavy losses
however it will ultimately protect him
and they come in conflicts carros asks
about the girl who visited him in the
hospital to which archie reveals that
she was hermino's younger sister she
gave him a number of letters himino had
written over the years many of which
discussed him in one highlighted passage
though we see that ximena had asked is
there anything that i can do to get aki
to quit which is something that shakes
him to his core
as they reach a chamber carrots reveals
that they intend for aki to make a
contract with a future devil they remark
on two previous agents who made a
contract with it one who gave up half of
their lifespan and the other who gave up
both of their eyes as well as their
sense of taste and smell
aki then enters the room and sees a
humanoid tree-like future devil emerged
from the shadows as it repeats the
phrase constantly the future is best the
future devil repeats phrases such as the
future rules and requests that argue
repeat them as well aki states his
intention of making a contract annoying
the devil the devil requests to read
ahi's future by placing his head in his
chest cavity
as he complies the devil begins giggling
profusely and agrees to the contract on
the condition that he can live in his
right eye
aki is shocked by the easiness of the
request however the devil mockingly
informs him that it wants to see his
future with its own eyes as he will die
in the worst way possible it asks if he
wants to know how he will die however
aki refuses before agreeing to the
contract unfazed at all
meanwhile dingy and power lay beeson on
a floor kashibe comments on their
improvements and informs them that their
training will become weekly instead of
daily he wants them to keep a cool head
and remain aware of their surroundings
before informing them that the new
fourth division will be hunting sawatari
and the katana man kishibi informs them
that if the mission fails the fourth
division will be shut down and he'll be
forced to kill them denji heavily
remarks though that if they were to
fight he'd spare kashibe as thanks for
making him stronger and moving him
closer to the goal of deity makima
later kashubi sits down to drink with
makima he remarks his unhappiness with a
continuing dingy and powers training due
to his growing attachment towards them
he then questions mahima on his
pre-existing knowledge of the attacks
remarking that as long as she's on
humanity's side he'll look the other way
maki mistakes her goal as being to save
as many people as possible and increase
the prestige of the fourth division
kishibe considers this before calling
her a liar makima smiles eerily in
response in an office building the gun
agents reconvene planning to put their
leader into hiding sawatari points out
the pointlessness of hiding given
mahima's power hearing this the katana
man agrees intending to kill dingy with
his own hands sawatari reveals the
group's ultimate weapon a cluster of
zombies left over by the zombie devil
elsewhere in a car as they drive arky
back home kuros asks him of his
intention to kill the gun devil he
states his annoyance commencing on the
ridiculous notion that a normal person
like aki could make any kind of impact
aki responds though that whilst the goal
is unrealistic he requires an
unrealistic outlook to make progress
crows tosses mikola saying that though
such an outlook irritates him he'll
still support it
meanwhile makima meets with a yakuza
boss he explains that though the gun
agents are members of his organization
he does not condone their actions he
elaborates that the factions were
influenced by sawatari who had had them
make small deals with the gun devil
paying money for guns and ammunition
maghima requests the names of every
yakuza member who contacted the gun
devil both within the bosses group and
his rivals however the boss refuses
explaining that such a betrayal would
cause all-out gang warfare resulting in
foreign mafias invading japan he then
calls the devil hunters idiots without
any real education causing his
compatriots to laugh at makima makimetho
places a small bag on the table she
explains as the man looks within it that
the eyeballs are from all of the family
members of every person in this room as
a boss looks in horror makima offers to
return them to their owners in return
for his cooperation
a yakuza grunt swings at her however he
immediately collapses with blood pouring
from his face
meanwhile the special forces of the
bureau prepare to storm the gun agent's
building inside sawatari talks to the
katana man reaffirming their plan to
kill as many devil hunters as possible
and steal denji's heart kishibe orders
the hunters to storm the building as a
pack of zombies lion weight
below them koshiba introduces himself to
the second division leader firono and
police officer sheena who are in charge
of locking down the building he gives a
rundown of the various non-human members
of the special fourth division inside
the building the shark thing beam
appears and begins devouring the zombies
in his frenzy he accidentally bites the
violence fiend who knocks him down
before apologizing attacking more
zombies the violence fan notices a woman
nearby and warns her to stay away before
realising that she is also a devil and
is in fact the spider devil she stands
up and decapitates a zombie whose head
falls at the feet of the angel devil who
begins eating away at their bodies arkey
appears and begins cutting through the
zombies the angel devil asks saki for a
hanky chief to clean up some blood
before explaining to him that he absorbs
others lifespans through touch and is
surprised at how close aki has got him a
gunman suddenly appears and tries
shooting at the two but the angel
deflects the bullet and aki stabs him
aki continues on his own eventually
coming face to face with sabotari
she uses her stake devil to release the
ghost devil which is now subservant to
her
aki moves forward deflecting most of the
ghost devil's attacks for the future
devil's future side however he is
quickly overwhelmed by the many arms of
the ghost devil and is soon being
strangled by the creature in a flashback
he remembers an early meeting with
himino in which she offered him a
cigarette however once she realizes that
he's underage she takes it back and
promises him to give it back to him when
he really needs to rely on something
in the present aki looks up having been
released from the ghost devil's grasp
from amongst its mass hemino's right arm
reaches out holding a cigarette taking
it aki sees the words easy revenge
written across it
taking a deep breath he steps forward
remembering himino's revise he reflects
that the ghost devil is blind and senses
its surroundings based on fear remaining
calm aki climbs a topic before promising
himeno that he'll die soon then he
decapitates the ghost devil a shock
sawatari moves to summon the snake devil
but is stopped by kabini holding a knife
to her throat aki orders kabini not to
kill her he then asks kabini why she
didn't quit the bureau to which she
awkwardly responds that she was close to
earning her bonus
dingy and power then arrive in the
headquarters using an elevator power
begins chomping on a severed zombified
hand disgusting dingy and causing the
two to scuffle as they argue the
elevator doors open revealing a swarm of
zombies in front of them due to the
zombies not noticing them dingy
recommends they stay quiet and utilize
the element of surprise power however
begins yelling loudly challenging the
zombies to combat power bravely steps
forward and begins fighting as a
bewildered and annoyed denji remains in
the elevator believing denji is still
watching her power easily slashes away
through dozens of whole king zombies
boasting that she is the strongest there
is
as denji's elevator arrives on the
highest floor he prepares to pull his
chainsaw's cord
the door opens and he sees the katana
man alongside a pair of gun agents the
katana man asks him to pause so we can
ask a few questions he explains the
group's desire for compensation over the
old man's death with denji frustratedly
explaining that the old man was
zombified when the devil killed him
however he doesn't believe this instead
the katana man asks denji whether he
truly felt nothing when killing the
zombies reminding him that they used to
be humans dingy though repeats that he
felt nothing
the katana man then reveals that despite
giving his heart to a devil unlike denji
he still feels guilt over killing
zombies explaining that denji is the
only devil human hybrid without a sense
of conscience he requests dingy to
accept his death as a form of mercy
killing but then she casually responds
that he doesn't wanna and an irritated
katana man takes off his hand and
becomes to transform in front of him the
two now transformed crash through a wall
and begin falling towards the streets
below the katana man and dingy still in
combat continue falling as denji is
pushed away he falls and lands atop a
moving train readjusting he is able to
block an attack from the still-falling
katana man which sends them crashing
into a crowded carriage as floods of
passengers flee a voice over announces
the train is coming to an emergency stop
denji notices a remaining passenger an
injured woman lying on the floor as the
katana man launches an attack denji
blocks her protecting the woman but
losing his arm in the process the woman
runs away as dingy angrily shout that
they should ban their move the katana
man then attacks again slighting off
denji's other arm he then demands that
as long as denji can no longer fight he
should apologize for killing the old man
and accept death however denji refuses
stating that as long as he has his
chainsaw on his head he can still fight
the two clash again however the impact
causes the blade on denji's chainsaw
head to shatter the katana man again
demands an apology in return for a swift
death but this time denji reveals that
the katana man was so distracted with
anger that he didn't notice being sliced
in half by denji's leg the katana man
now revealed to have been split
vertically reacts with a moment of
surprise before his body completely
falls apart into a mass of blood and
organs watching deja repeats the words
told to him by kishibe prey should never
trust what a hunter says
a little while later and now outside the
stopped train the katana man now
reverted to human form and wearing
nothing but underwear awakens next to
the train bound by a set of chains or
blades
a shirtless stingy stands over him
expressing his surprise over his speedy
recovery an infuriated katana man
threatens to kill him but dingy rebuffs
it calling him a loser dingy states that
he is waiting for the police to come and
arrest him however he notes that he is
unwilling to accept the katana man
merely facing imprisonment after being
responsible for himino's death as aki
arrives then she announces he's planning
a tournament as revenge then she asks
saki if you'd like to join in on the
tournament stating that he shot himino
so his punishment should be nut shots he
then reveals the rules of his tournament
taking it in turns to kick the katana
man in his testicles with whomever can
make him scream the loudest before the
police arrive being crowned the winner
loudly sighing aki states it's not their
job to torture him and himino would be
unhappy with such actions however after
looking at the cigarette he was given by
the ghost devil he rolls up his sleeves
and asks about the reward for the winner
dingy responds how they get to keep the
remains of his testicles
somewhere across the city the remaining
gun agents are rounded up while the
angel devil looks into the distance
the scene returns to the katana man
screaming in pain as aki and denji
excitedly beat into him as he kicks him
aki thinks of himino stating that his
screams of pain are their requiem for
her
elsewhere makima reports the events of
the date of the bureau
they question why the gun agents desired
dingy's heart but makima reveals that
the snake devil killed salwatari before
she could be questioned likely as a part
of their contract makima reveals though
that with the gun devil's fragments
they've collected from the gun agents
they have a mass large enough to begin
indicating the location of the gun devil
that night dingy has a dream of standing
in front of a door he notes that the
dream is reoccurring from the other side
an eye looks in as pachita's voice
repeats his name
happily denji asks patrita to enter so
he can pet him however vegeta ominously
tells him to never open this door
then she then awakens in a cold sweat he
looks over and sees aki and power
napping beside him power is reawakened
by dingy shouts setting up and revealing
that she has grown several new horns
commenting on them power responds by
punching him the knock is powerful
enough to send him flying across the
room and surprise the both of them later
on while observing power's new enlarged
horns makima informs denji that she has
ingested too much blood from these
zombies and requires some to be drained
in order to decrease her strength to
make her less unruly dingy agrees
causing power to nervously sweat makima
reveals that walt's power is busy he has
been partnered with a shark fiend called
beam beam then suddenly appears from the
floor attempting to hug dingy but a
surprise dingy knocks him down making
mistakes that beam has a distinct
fondness for denji and has promised to
follow any of his orders notion denji is
in a bad mood makima invites him out on
a date
the next day denji excitedly waits for
her to arrive arriving several hours
early makima also shows up early and
reveals that the pair are going to have
a movie marathon at a local cinema
non-stop until midnight during the first
film denji notes that he isn't laughing
with the rest of the audience looking at
makima he sees that she is not laughing
either after the film makima briefly
critiques her commenting on the plot and
cinematography they pair attend the next
film and denji again notices that he and
makima are the only ones not reacting to
the film
again as the film ends makima critiques
it the cycle continues throughout the
day with dingy growing continuously
bored before they enter the final film
denji comments that none of the films
had any impacts on him comey seen that
he may just not really get films making
responds that she is the same however
the very few that she did react to
changed her life as they view their next
film then she is shocked to find himself
crying at a seemingly trivial scene
looking at makima he sees she is also
silently crying the two then leave the
cinema and good spirits talking about
how they enjoyed the last film then she
questions mahima as to whether she
believes he has a heart and in response
she leans in and listens to his
heartbeat before telling him that he
certainly does
she smiles and walks away leaving dingy
blushing in the middle of the street
so after making her leaves dingy walks
down the street happily thinking of the
date noting a charity stand dingy
donates money as a sign of his new found
heart and is given a flower as thanks he
happily walks away munching the flower
to the complete beliment of the girl of
the stand while walking dingy thinks of
how makima's words were able to calm his
pent-up concerns he assures himself that
he will use the wish that she promised
him and thanks on how she will be the
only girl he will ever be romantically
interested in suddenly it begins raining
and denji decides to run for cover he
tries to wait out the storm in a
telephone booth when a young woman
suddenly enters surprising him she
apologizes and begins laughing much to
his confusion gradually though her
laughter turns to tears before saying
that his face reminds her of her
deceased dog
denji suddenly begins gagging and pulls
the flower out of his throat presenting
it to the girl she thanks him and smiles
and as the rain stops she invites him to
visit her workplace a cafe called
futamichi arriving at work she puts on
an apron and notices that denji is
already waiting for her the girl sits
next to him ordering a pair of coffees
for the two of them while drinking she
laughs and flirtatiously touches his
shoulder she then introduces herself as
razor with dingy also introducing
himself okay quick note i know i was
getting names wrong here but like
literally i don't know why i don't know
how to pronounce her name it's it's a
mind twister for me right now to be
honest anyway back to the story dingy
worriedly thinks of makima as he
realizes that his feelings for reza are
growing suspiciously fast
meanwhile aki is on duty with the angel
devil hoping to kill more devils and
earn respect within the bureau so as to
be put on the gun devil task force the
angel devil complains though instead
wanting to sit and just eat ice cream
but arki warns him that a lack of
cooperation will lead to the angel's
extermination considering this angel
concludes that dying is slightly more
effort than work and agrees to move
in a flashback we find makima
introducing the angel devil to aki
makima explains that the angel devil is
the most powerful hunter besides kishibe
she elaborates more that he has the
ability to absorb the life force of
anyone he touches transforming them
instead into weapons with powerful
properties going on to say that when he
was discovered he'd absorbed an entire
village
later the pair stand over the corpse of
a devil that they had just killed the
angel devil discovers the dying body of
a civilian devil hunter and aki requests
that the angel devil should kill the man
painlessly but he refuses stating that
as a devil he believes all humans should
only suffer as they die so instead arki
kills the man and the pair calmly
conclude that neither of them can get
along on a personal level over with
denji he returns back to the cafe unsure
of whether his heart lies with makima or
not as he enters razzie comments that
he's eaten here every day that week she
then invites him to sit at her table and
he mentions how he is unable to read he
reveals that the only kanji he can write
is balls causing her to crack up
laughing he states his desire to learn
how to read and hearing this rezay moves
in closer and invites him to attend
night school with her nervously and
extremely flustered dengy then accepts
elsewhere a scarred half-naked man looks
down into a water-filled sink he speaks
to the typhoon devil asking why the
devil's desire to chainsaw devil's heart
from in the sink the typhoon devil's
voice emerges responding that he doesn't
need to know instead only reminding him
of the terms of their contract which is
the complete use of its powers forever
in return for denji's chainsaw heart
however the man still isn't pleased and
he goes on to tell a story about how he
killed a highly fed chinese devil hunter
by kidnapping murdering and skinning his
entire family after that the devil
hunter simply let him kill him without
even a fight
later that night deji and rezay walk
through the empty school rezzy comments
that she's scared and asks to hold
dingy's hand dingy agrees whilst also
internally apologizing to makima later
and sat in the classroom now rezay
pretends to teach deji some simple
nonsensical facts such as oneplus one
equals two and how to write the phrase
big dumpy in english she comments on the
lack of education asking whether his
life as a devil hunter is truly good for
him he responds though that his job
allows him three square meals and a
beard but razzie reminds him that those
are the bare minimal acceptable living
conditions in the first place denoting
dingy's growing uneasiness whereas this
is yes that they go swimming now by the
pool outside reza strips down completely
nude denji admits he doesn't even know
how to swim but instantly strips down as
well
though still filled with uncertainty
deji eventually jumps in as rezai begins
to show him how to swim eventually it
begins raining and the two return
indoors they sit inside watching the
rain and rezay asks denji if he'd rather
be the city mouse or the country mouse
meanwhile aki and the angel devil are
still talking
angel explains that the country mouse
lives in a safer yet less fulfilling
life whilst the country mouse lives in a
more dangerous but more enjoyable life
angela elaborates that he'd rather be a
country mouse however was brought by
makima to the city and forced to be a
city mouse at the same time dingy
concludes that he'd rather be a city
mouse as his only real desires are for
food and entertainment regardless of the
danger after hearing this reza invites
him to a food festival that is taking
place the next day she then leaves to
use the bathroom after she leaves dingy
quietly calls her so freaking cute under
his breath as rezay walks the corridor
alone she is approached by this scarred
man wielding a knife at the same time
dingy begins to panic as he realizes he
now sees rezay standing alongside makima
when he closes his eyes i really really
hope i'm pronouncing her name right
because in my head it just doesn't even
feel right right now meanwhile reyes is
chased outside onto a rooftop she asks
who the scarred man is but he merely
responds that she has the cheese to act
as bait for dingy he then informs her
that he plans to peel her face off and
gouge out her eyes in order to torture
her and control denji as he lunges at
her she swiftly dodges his attack though
and swings onto his back and then begins
choking him out with little effort as he
slowly starts to die she sings him a
sweet russian lullaby as rezay stands up
she calmly looks down at the typhoon
devil in a nearby dream the devil
apologizes to her calling her miss rezay
and she promises to overlook its
accidents in return for removing the
scarred man's corpse swiftly she then
returns to denji with a beautiful smile
on her face the next day the two hang
out at the festival in the evening they
climb into a hill to view the fireworks
turning to him rezzy asks him to quit
devil hunting and run away with her
promising to make him happy and protect
him heavily conflicted then she asks why
rezzy wants to run away with him with
her telling him that she likes him
though denji admits he's tempted he
explains that he's grown more happy with
his current situation his increasing
position amongst the bureau as well as
better relationships with aki and power
headmits these are not things he's
willing to give up on so easily he asks
if he can still see her despite this but
she asks if he is someone else he likes
before grabbing him intensely and
kissing him however though and running
with a tradition of dingy having bad
luck he falls backwards and it is
revealed that a head bitten off his
tongue instantly dingy moves to try and
pull his cord but rezay swiftly slices
off his hand before he could do so
then kneeling in close and holding him
gently rosie kisses him again before
apologising and calmly telling him she
intends to take his heart but before she
can even move the actual goat who i
completely forgot about beam bursts
through the floor and grabs his best boy
dingy then without hesitation fleeing
with him down the hill as he runs beam
curses air himself for not recognizing
her smell the smell of a bomb
as he stays this she pulls the pin out
of her choker and her head and right arm
explode they then quickly reform
revealing her transformed state which is
that of a bomb devil hybrid she screams
at beam calling him a thief then uses a
powerful blast ability to launch herself
flying towards the duo crashing in front
of them seemingly in an instant still
clutching dingy beam attempts to flee
from rezay however she is able to use
powerful explosive blasts to launch
herself in front of him and block his
path she offers to let him go in return
for dingy however beam growls and
transforms into a giant shark-headed
creature yet and seemingly with little
to no effort ryze touches his face
though hitting him with an explosion
knocking him down a trio of private
devil hunters then appear and report the
situation over a walkie-talkie snapping
her fingers reset explodes the three of
them before turning back and noticing
their beam had already fled with denji
nearby at the second division's training
facility aki spas with some hunters one
hunter nomo thanks him for the training
before requesting he worked for them and
promising him a high ranking position in
five years
as they leave the angel devil asks aki
why he didn't mention his short life
spam revealing that power informed him
of it the angel devil calls aki lucky
revealing his desire to die as so to
avoid effort
suddenly nomu rushes around the corner
requesting their aid at the entrance
they see a heavily injured bean
clutching dingy's tatted body beam
informs aki that the bomb hybrid is
coming and reveals the bomb devil to be
the gun devil's partner when aki
questions why he knows this information
beam reveals he promised mahima he
wouldn't tell under threat of death nomo
then notices a young girl a human formed
reza approaching the facility she
requests their aid claiming to have been
attacked by a devil however nomo note a
wide smile on her face as they move
dingy and beam nomo comments that rezei
seems familiar asking aki if he
recognizes her noting that they won't
simply let her answer rezay prepares to
pull out the pin in her neck commenting
that she'll have to massacre them all
instead before reza can attack two
hunters kato and tanabe use an unknown
devil's ability to grow mould in her
heart and intestines stunning her as she
coughs up blood they comment that their
mould will continue to grow even if she
regenerates as the pair plan to stall
her until she is consumed in retaliation
rezzy fires a blast at her own head
decapitating herself reza's still moving
torso flings the head at the devil
hunters as he heads says boom it
releases a sudden burst and transforms
into the fully formed bomb hybrid whilst
the hunters are distracted by the attack
the torso runs towards them no more
attempts to stop her using the fox devil
to attack however the torso dodges and
grabs him before exploding numerous
hunters are then seen dead as the
reformed rezai continues the assault
blasting away the other survivors nomo
though having survived the explosion on
him attempts to attack again yet again
though rezay dodges each hit but before
she can execute him the second division
lieutenant appears summoning khan to
swallow her hole
the success was in vain however as khan
quickly disappears leaving the bomb
devil to continue her assault meanwhile
aki prepares to drive the angel devil
the unconscious dingy and beam away from
the building he orders angel to give
blood to denji to which the angel devil
reluctantly complies but before they can
start though aki complains of an unknown
vision he just received from the future
devil suddenly as the car starts rosie
appears clutching his severed heads of
nomo and the lieutenants she explains
that she killed the two of them as a
sign of strength stating that she'd
rather not kill and ask in the group to
just leave dingy behind and flee aki not
listening swiftly drives the car and
swerves around her attempting to escape
rezay leaps atop the vehicle with a
blast irritatedly commenting on how the
gasoline within the car will cause a
fire although before she can even attack
she is ambushed and knocked back with a
kick from the violence vein aki leans
out of the car window shouting that he
called for backup earlier on thanking
the violence fame the fan kicks everest
again however to a surprise she is able
to block his attack complimenting the
violence fiend on its strength rezai
prepares to fight yet the theme noting
how much weaker he is calls out kabini
stating that the bomb devil is stronger
than them and it's actually time for a
tactical retreat turning around whereas
he sees kabini on the floor having
actually fallen down with an injured hip
she begins crying and begging for her
life crawling up into a ball on the
floor luckily though as she sobbed frese
spared her and chased after dingy
in the car aki continues driving down a
packed motorway looking out the window
angel sees rezay moving through the sky
blasting herself towards their position
she lands on a large truck immediately
behind them as dingy awakes from his
days gasping for air aki tells the
others that as a last resort he'll ram
the car directly into her as their main
goal is to keep dingy away from her
however not listening then she
transforms into the chainsaw devil
slicing his way through the car as he
begins to rampage towards her now facing
the bomb devil then she angrily screams
telling her that every woman he has ever
met has tried to kill him then
proceeding to ask why are so many people
interested in the chainsaw's heart but
not him risley asks him that her
feelings for him were genuine causing
dingy to hesitate for a moment yet aki
yells out to him stabbing him back to
reality and telling him not to be so
damn gullible then she comments that he
no longer needs her as he actually has
makima whereas they show surprise before
saying that their two running away
together would have been meaningless if
makima held influence over him now just
pissed off denji yells that he doesn't
want anyone else to die because of him
and instead only plans to capture her
before he launches himself directly at
the bomb devil entering combat reza
immediately erupts destroying the truck
her and dingy was standing on being
knocked backwards into a building dingy
is also punched in the face by rezay and
is flung back even further she then
begins chastising him going on to prove
her point rezzy reveals she allowed
dingy to actually slice off one of her
fingers which is now caught on dingy's
chain instantly the severed finger then
explodes catching denji off guard as
rezay looks into the cloud of smoke left
by the blast denji leaps out and
attempts to attack her again
nevertheless reza's reflexes prove to be
too quick as she blasts the pair up into
the sky
moving through the air razik transforms
her leg into a missile immediately
launching the two back down to the
ground again and literally tearing
dingy's torso apart blow as
blood-covered civilians look on reza
picks up denji's severed torso and
blasts it rendering it into nothing but
a heap of blood and smoldering flesh as
rezai moves through the ruined building
she steps over corpses leaving behind a
number of injured survivors it is then
revealed that that sneaky ol archie is
actually hiding amongst the corpses
pretending to be dead as rezai moves
past him he quickly stands up and slices
off her arm causing her to drop denji
aki moves him to attack rezai again
however after seeing a vision from the
future devil he instantly moves back and
begins to dodge her attacks in
retaliation where they transforms her
arm into a missile and hits the ground
causing a massive explosion she is
knocked back by her own blast but
luckily for aki the violence fiend
arrives managing to grab and pull him
out of the blast into safety the
violence fiend apologizes for his poor
timing but aki jokingly comments that
he's never been so glad to see a damn
devil as they too look to rezay she
pauses and asks for a timeout commenting
that she has lost a lot of blood and a
two against one fight in these
conditions is just unfair randomly the
fiend agrees asking aki if they should
accept a handicap in the fight however
aki just fled out refuses rezay then
reveals her hesitation was merely a ploy
as now a monstrously massive typhoon
devil appears crashing through a nearby
building and offering to enter the fight
and assist her nearby the angel devil
moves through the rubble absorbing the
life of the dying victims moving over to
dingy's torso which is now being
clutched by the bff beam angel gives him
blood restoring our boy back to full
string beam is delighted commenting on
how dingy is super cool angel tells
dingy he needs to choose whether he
wants to die and give reza his heart or
kill her then she thinks on this for a
moment before deciding to kill her
stating that it's an easy choice dingy
worries about reza's enormous strength
and the angel devil asks beam for advice
commenting that he seems to have a
greater knowledge of the chainsaw devil
beam suggests that dingy should use his
chainsaws to move more quickly by
wrapping the chainsaws around objects
and swinging from building to building
dingy grows excited at the prospect of
expanding his power and orders beam to
transform into a shark as he does dingy
jumps onto his back and uses the chains
of his chainsaw as a set of reins hoping
to control beam like a horse both beam
and the angel devil comment on this
nonsensical method of movement however
then she ignores them instead then she
sends beam charging towards the enemy as
the two move forward the typhoon devil
greets them excitedly as the combined
strength of the explosion and typhoon
send the others flying back the violence
thing comments that they can do nothing
now but simply watch the struggle
between denji beam rezay and the typhoon
devil in the battle denji moves in and
is able to slice off their bomb devil's
leg but the typhoon devil gives her some
of his juice healing her both denji and
reza express excitement over the
insanity of the conflict as the flurry
continues the angel devil is blasted
back aki grabs his shirt yeah he also
begins to lose his grip on the signpost
he was holding onto for dear life angel
calls out for him telling him to just
let go as he has already accepted his
death as aki begins to lose his grip on
the angel devil's shirt the devil closes
his eyes and thinks of a young woman
from his past suddenly arki grabs the
devil's hand and pulls him back into
safety pissed off though the angel devil
angrily asks him why aki grabbed his
hand as doing so cost him another two
months of his already short life span
aki responds that if the angel devil
were to die he'd rather it were done at
a distance as he said enough of watching
people die in front of his eyes back in
the conflict dingy is able to easily
slice the typhoon devil to shreds losing
the sight of rezai though she attacks
the peer from above blasting dingy and
beam into the ground crawling out of a
semi-conscious beam's mouth dingy
reveals their being took the brunt of
the blast now standing up he and rezay
finally face just one another on a
rooftop playfully she asks him to give
up however our boy the legend the
freaking chainsaw man responds that he
doesn't want her hearing this in pissed
rosie flicks a small blast at dingy
erupting his right arm and igniting him
with fire moving in closer an irritated
rezai asks him to accept death she
comments that he has nowhere else to run
but dingy responds saying that she had
actually made a mistake pointing out the
ocean that is stationed behind them
reminding her that she had taught him
how to swim she flicks another blast at
his other arm and as the smoke clears it
is revealed that dingy managed to keep
the arm attached to his torso by
connecting the chain between his
shoulder and forearm flinging the
chainsaw frizzy he manages to wrap her
up before suddenly leaping into the
ocean with her and because she is unable
to explode whilst wet she sinks to the
bottom and becomes unconscious
the next morning now after the fight she
reawakens in a human form lying next to
denji and a sleeping beam on a nearby
beach she asks him why he revived her
and he responds that he did it for his
own sake as he felt that allowing her to
be captured or killed would haunt him
she reminds him that she could easily
kill him to what she playfully responds
if i'm gonna die at least let it be at
the hands of a beautiful woman rizzy
begins to laugh telling him that she
never really liked him in the first
place and every flirtatious interaction
from her was just part of her plan as
she starts to leave though then she asks
to leave with her and go on the run
confused in questioning him he tells her
that he genuinely likes her and reminds
her that even if all her comments were a
lie she still taught him how to swim
which implies some kind of genuine
affection
rezay moves closer to dingy before
swiftly snapping his neck and walking
away as she leaves him lying there dingy
calls out to her inviting her to the
cafe that day at noon as she changes her
mind about running away skipping forward
now to later in that day denji packs his
bags and heads out to the cafe
elsewhere aki and kishibe watch as they
clean up for the previous night's fights
go on kishibe tells aki a russian urban
legend of a ussr military branch that
performs human testing on children
explaining the story to be true khasheba
reveals that rezay was actually one of
those children with her true name ben
morimoto
nearby rezay moves to a train station
planning to run away however while
sitting there at the station she chooses
not to actually enter the train and
instead to walk to the cafe that denji
is at as she moves through an alleyway
towards it she begins to smile with
anticipation however suddenly a mob of
mice run by her feet forming a large
pillar in front of her a voice is heard
from within it as the mice fall away it
is revealed to be makima she states that
she refers the country mouse in
reference to the conversation between
rezay and dingy a few nights prior
nevertheless makima reveals her reason
for liking the country mouse as it's
based on her enjoyment of capturing and
killing them an activity she describes
as giving her peace of mind rosie moves
to pull the pin on her neck however in
an eerily similar way of what she did to
dingy her arm is instantly obliterated
before she can even react making my
moves and hits her in the chest knocking
her back mid-stumble she is also impaled
by a spear thrown from a rooftop by the
angel devil as reza slowly begins to
bleed out makima takes her hand and
looking at the cafe rezay thinks of
denji wondering on the reason she didn't
even kill him on their first date was it
also because like dingy she never been
to school either and was just as excited
as he was makima tells the angel devil
that he was supposed to bring arky with
him but also comments that it was nice
to leave him behind as he wouldn't have
reacted well to executing a woman angel
agrees before looking down at her mouse
and asking it if the city is a nice
place
inside the cafe dingy sits despondently
clutching a bouquet of flowers
the owner speaks to him promising that
another girl will eventually come along
one who is just perfect for him as he
says this the door then opens and power
walks in she shouts that she followed
dingy sent to the cafe having been
allowed back to work then she lets out a
low disheartened sigh as power sits next
to him thinking that the bouquet dingy
was holding is for her power demands
that he'd give her the flowers and as
the two look at each other then she
quickly shoves them all into his mouth
scoffing them down smiling
now we skip forward to inside of denji's
mind while he's having another nightmare
standing in front of the same door from
an earlier nightmare he once again hears
bachita ordering him to never open the
door
the next morning at breakfast denji sits
despondently as power complains about
maoi's newfound love of him then she
ignores her thinking of reset and how
his heart was truly and irreversibly
broken by her this time but when mahima
later invites them all on a paid
vacation with her his mood does a
complete una reverse gambit which causes
denji to jump with joy aki and denji
instantly agree whilst power tries to
make up an excuse not to go as they
discuss the timing for the trip a group
of devil hunters suddenly enter the room
after conferring with makima she shows
the group a news recording of the fight
against rezay explaining the bureau had
failed to censor the broadcast and as
such the chainsaw man's existence has
been revealed to the world
power and dingy ignore this still
discussing the vacation but they are
interrupted by makima who explains that
their vocation was a ruse to explain
their absence and in reality they are
going to be put under protection in
order to avoid assassination by foreign
threats then she reacts with horror as
he realizes that he is going to be
restricted and contained for some time
makima asks aki to be a part of dingy's
protection before telling him that they
plan to hunt the gun devil in the next
year and orders him to not die
beforehand aki thinks back to a
conversation he had with the angel devil
who explains the supposed true nature of
devils when a devil dies they are
revived within hell once they die there
they then return to earth with no
memories of the time in hell he then
reveals a secret he asks to never be
repeated that all devils remember just a
single sound from their moment before
they die in hell
the sound of the chainsaw devil
meanwhile in america a trio of part-time
devil hunters sit and discuss their new
job killing dingy and returning his body
to the us in exchange for two million of
those beautiful american buckaroos
the youngest man aldo expresses a fear
of dying however as talked down by the
other two reminding him that the three
of them all brothers survived the gun
devil's onslaught as they prepare to
leave for japan their leader saito
refers to them as immortal
elsewhere in a forest a woman and a
young man named tulka hunts a fox as he
shoots the fox the woman asks if he felt
like he'd taken the fox's life but the
man explains that he did not as he skins
the animal she asks him again and again
he says no
as he cooks it and serves it to her she
asks again once more and yet again he
denies it the woman then explains that
they will be going to japan and doing
the same to a young 16 year old boy
named denji the man referring to the
woman as master agrees hoping to earn
the woman a retirement due to her short
life span meanwhile in china the
halaseki seki funtime takes place
between a woman named kuan xi and a
hareem of i guess you could say friends
as they start nutting a man arrives
requesting her to take the job of
capturing denji they chainsaw devil and
as a reward she can ask for any wish
after consulting her group she demands
basic human rights and an education for
all of them at the same time mahima
discusses quan shi with kashibe
expressing concern over her and her
hareem's abilities as they talk makima
states that the biggest concern is that
of the assassin santa claus from germany
yo ho ho though he is thought to have
died of old age the two are still
cautious as kashibe confirms his
abilities could likely outmatch them
elsewhere in germany a government agent
approaches an old man on a bench and
informs him of the mission to hunt denji
in return the man asks for four children
three for a devil contract and one for
pleasure wait what the what the [__]
does he mean by that like bro chill
yo like calm down meanwhile alone in his
room dingy lies watching tv sadly
wondering why his heart is so desired
and also why the trip was cancelled
noticing his sadness aki affectionately
sits on him explaining that the trip was
merely postponed not cancelled and that
if they're able to damage their
opponents enough then the enemy will
retreat allowing denji to return to his
life as normal denji considering the
idea instead decides to kill all of his
enemies so that he can finally have his
vacation
skipping forward and now at the park
both dingy and power eat snacks while
watching some birds and talking about
whether it's okay to eat the still
living ducks dingy accidentally drops
his food but as he goes to pick it up
and eat it he is stopped by a devil
hunter named kusakabe and then chastised
by him kusukabe warns him of germs and
food poisoning but denji grows more
frustrated as obviously our man's from
the gutter aki and angel yoshida and
tamaoki also all agree that eating the
food would just be straight up stupid
however the forever ignorant dingy
quickly gobbles it down anyway in a
flashback we see the group all
introducing themselves makima explains
to dingy that they alongside another
trio of agents will be his personal
security kusukabe attempts to express
his authority over denji but has met
with our boys typical sarcasm and new
ones elsewhere the hunters tendo carroz
and subaru or take ziggy breaks
questioning why they can't simply hide
denji in his human form subaru explains
that the other devils can actually smell
him as they drive to meet the main group
subaru asks about makima tendo hesitates
before saying there's something he wants
to discuss regarding her before they can
though a set of road spikes are
bizarrely thrown in front of the vehicle
the car swerves in an attempt to miss
them but runs over the spikes and
crashes in the wreckage subaru awakens
just in time to see the three american
boys rolling up outside the vehicle
sadly for subaru and good old floridian
style the americans shoot the three
hunters dead afterwards the elder two
brothers crack jokes about it but aldo
the youngest reacts with horror to the
murders now hiding the bodies settle
asks joey about his feelings on kelling
with joey the anime man stating his only
response to be a mild annoyance and
disgust sato cracks up laughing before
morphing his face to match there of
course's the three men then discuss his
voice and how it would sound as satou
shifts his tone and accent in an attempt
to match it back with the main crew they
away within a burger restaurant as denji
and power eats power offers dingy her
vegetables however kusakabe interrupts
ordering her to finish them off for her
own health the others agree as then she
forces them into her mouth power begins
to sweat choking down a mixture of
vegetables and vomit just then the woman
from the forest walks past the table the
power and frustration over what just
happened runs outside causing the rest
to follow the woman sits at a table with
tolka revealing that she'd stab dingy
three times with a nail in order to
invoke the cursed devil and that only
one more poke is required she entrusts
the final poke to tulka as she begins to
munch into her burger though she
struggles due to her numb hand and weak
senses she is delighted by the
experience elsewhere the violence fiend
and kabini walk outside she thanks him
for purchasing her an ice cream cone
then questioning his role as the
violence fiend given his friendliness he
explains that he still has a lot of his
human brain left meaning that he still
holds a lot of his early human memories
however he has no memories whatsoever of
his death only that he was saved by
mahima suddenly a car pulls up beside
them and inside the american bad boy
sato now disguised as kuros gets out he
then tells the two to report tendo and
subaru's death to hq before quietly
commenting to himself on their obvious
gullibility later on benji and power sit
exhausted after a day of constant
movement then she bitterly comments that
rather than being protected he is
instead being used as bait to draw out
the enemy to which arki actually
confirms he promises denji his trip
calming him however power is still
furious
aki promises her one reward for her
cooperation with her requesting to drain
a human of their blood to the point that
they die
aki pauses for a moment and then agrees
to let her drain dingy but he
immediately protests yet he is quickly
silenced by power jumping on his
shoulders and screaming with the
excitement of a literal cannibal the
violence fame cabinet and the disguised
american bad boy drive over to meet with
the main group american bad boy i'm just
saying that because he's the only like
westerner i think on this entire show so
far so i'm looking to give the
westerners some rep you know what i mean
like gunslinging american bad boy don't
worry about me anyway they tried to eat
the rest of the group aki speaks with
the brother disguised as kuros asking
him to reconsider his place on the
mission however he lies claiming he
wishes to avenge tendo and subaru as
they continue talking power is
distracted by kabini's car
in her typical powerful fashion she
flies into the front seat lying about
having a driver's license and claiming
that the car is actually hers and was
stolen by kabini though kabini quietly
protests it she is silenced by power
sherily threatening her asking as she
wants the car to be washed into her
blood
outside the vehicle as the fake heroes
suspiciously introduces himself to dingy
trying to be hella touchy and shake his
hand power suddenly jolts the car
forward ramming into both of them and
actually murking the disguised american
as the group all reacts with horror and
power attempts to blame kabini for the
incident kusakabe suddenly calls out
pointing at the brothers disguise which
is now slipping away revealing his true
face tamaoki recognizes him warning the
others of his contract with his skin
devil and the likelihood of his brothers
also being nearby
aki turns to power who though previously
panicking and blaming kabini quickly
begins to claim she knew the truth all
along stating that the glory is all hers
while indica kabini remained sweating
and sobbing in horror close by two
civilians are shown to be watching the
scene in terror they moved to an
alleyway as not to be seen and it is
revealed that they are the americans
joey and aldo in disguise aldo vomits as
joey attempts to collect himself and
come up with a plan however he is
suddenly pulled around a corner by an
unseen figure and is seemingly vaporized
aldo quickly composes himself as yoshida
a devil hunter walks around the corner
having swiftly executed joey noting
aldo's vomit he writes him off as a
bystander and leaves quietly muttering
that a pro wouldn't puke
somewhere in tokyo a car rams into
another as one driver leans his head out
to confront the other has met by cosmo
who cheerily repeats the phrase
halloween to him the driver slowly
begins to repeat the phrase to himself
over and over quan shi appears and
begins leading cosmo and the other girls
in her group away noticing a sushi
restaurant pingasty grows excited as
they enter the staff express fear of the
group but begin serving them either way
as cosmo makes them repeat halloween too
whilst they wait for their food pingasty
another member of the group begins to
list off facts about fish and long takes
a bite out of a ceramic plate then
stating she is exhausted quan she
instead decides to hunt denchi the next
day oh my
i think is how you say it properly and
quan she uh like her group's names are
so hard to say like my brain though like
literally cut cope try to say them
i try so hard elsewhere aldu observes a
photo of carroz tendo and their friend
tomono disguising himself as carroz he
goes to domino's apartments who invites
him inside sitting down together he asks
of tomino's life tomino goes on to
reveal that he has few relatives or
acquaintances who barely ever check up
on him he then begins to ask questions
regarding carroz's life revealing that
carroz had a girlfriend and a mother
both of whom who cared deeply about him
aldo turned and sees a photo of a young
caros as part of a soccer team seeing
this he breaks down repeating i'm sorry
much to domino's bewilderments
later as the two lie down to sleep
tomorrow speaks to carroz still not
realising as the disguised aldo he
invites him to quit devil hunting and
open up a small clothing shop instead
then bringing up carroz's deceased older
brother asking him what would he say
about carroz's current position then
thinking on his brothers aldo realises
the advice they would give him would be
a pro always gets his job done the next
day in a crowded street in japan the
mysterious old german man is seen
touching a passerby on the shoulder the
duty touched then gasps and grabs out
that he passed by next to them and so
forth until the entire street had linked
itself converting into doll-like
creatures along the way
throughout the cities the four different
groups tulka and huharim aldo the
elderly man and quan shi all prepare in
various ways to begin hunting the
chainsaw devil
elsewhere in a building makima walks
through a cluster of doll-like corpses
she orders beam and prince to go and
protect denji whilst making the
protection of the other hunters only a
secondary objective at an apartment
store the creepy old dude watches dingy
and the others through a window from a
distance he commands his dolls to attack
the group once they enter the building
following their party inside the doll's
arms warp into blades however as they
enter through the door kusakabe is
revealed to be crouching inside of a
ritual circle then using the power of
the stone devil he petrifies the
approaching dolls yoshida explains the
power of the doldival stay seen that if
they touch any part of a person
including the clothes that they wear
they will be transformed into a
subservient doll as aki suggests that
there would be a limit to the amount
that could be made a large swarm of
dolls instantaneously burst through the
windows charging towards the group as
they run to the second floor power is
suddenly grabbed as her and dingy rip
their dolls to pieces kusukabe reveals
that things are likely and luckily
immune to the dull devil's powers as
more swarm a hunter named nakamura
suddenly appears summoning the fox devil
to swipe them away bro this guy's
probably going to die as we know who
every single fox devil use of this this
dude just leaves when he starts getting
attacked too hard tamaoki explains to
everyone that there were hunters
stationed in every building in the
street and that the mission's true
purpose was to hunt the assassin
creating the dolls called santa claus
explaining that those turned into dolls
can never be restored he notes that the
ability is short-ranged meaning that the
assassin is in the nearby vicinity and
apologizes to denji for using him as
bait over with the woman she sits at a
nearby park waiting close by tulka
clutches his nail preparing to use it on
denji in the bathroom of the department
store aldo sits psyching himself up for
the coming conflicts the elderly man
summons another swarm of dolls to attack
as kabini attempts to repair the dent in
her car and kwon shi finally prepares to
hunt
it's just a free for right now i love
this part of the story so much as more
dolls are created by the old man they
begin flowing inside the store dodging
the fox devil swipes and lunging forward
angel summons one of his weapons using
five years worth of his lifespan that he
had absorbed from humans then strikes
down several of the approaching dolls
when questioned as to why he had used
such a weapon earlier he responds that
he has his reasons outside a group of
devil hunters appear preparing to aid
the group however they are halted by the
appearance of quan shi and uharim as
they prepare to attack the girls kwon
shi pulls out a sword and dashes forward
making your way to the second floor of
the building in almost an instant
dropping the now dented swords she draws
two more as the hunters and dolls are
revealed to have been sliced apart
having seen a vision of the events
through his future site ike warns the
others as he and the angel devil are
barely able to block her continued
attacks being knocked to the floor
nakamura who was too slow to react is
decapitated by her barrage i told you
this man would die quan she then stands
up looking back at a consumed dingy in
power
outside members of quanchi's team wait
destroying the remaining dolls suddenly
they are approached by kashibe kabini
and the violence theme pingasty uses her
ability to see that kashibe has
contracts with the needle claw and knife
devils before assessing him as harmless
due to his lack of body parts with which
he hasn't already made contracts kishibe
slowly strikes towards them as they
prepare to fight
inside the building aki's group reacted
quan shi's instantaneous attacks in a
flash she kicks denji into the air
before knocking out kusakabe and tamaoki
moving towards yoshida he summons the
octopus devil to absorb the brunt of the
attack before spraying the rest of the
room with a mist of ink attempting to
take it by surprise yoshida moves behind
kwon shi but is quickly knocked down but
before she can kill him kishibe
intervenes having already taken long and
pingasty host stage kishibe orders denji
and power to restrain the hostages as
power reveals that she was actually just
playing dead the entire time kishibe and
kuan shi who are revealed to actually be
past acquaintances sit down to discuss
the situation kishibe begins to discuss
retirement and old age however as he
speaks he holds up notes in a notepad
that reveal makima is listening to them
through his notepad he promises to give
kwanshi freedom in return for helping
kill makima kwon shi refuses explaining
through a seemingly unrelated anecdote
that she prefers not to get involved
stay tuned their ignorance is bliss as
she says this aldo enters and shoots at
denji koshibay kicks denji though
causing the attack to miss but long is
still able to take the opportunity to
grapple him and free herself then in a
flash both quan shi and kishibe move to
slice each other's throats
after a few strikes kwon shi is able to
throw kishibe out of the window but he
is able to slow his fall by sliding down
the building's exterior and falling the
top of kabini's car
aldo continues to fire at the various
combatants leaping out of the way of a
fireball shot by long however quanchi
grabs him and throws him through the
window as well with him also falling and
landing on kabini's car inside of the
building the violence thing continues
fighting of a swarm of dolls as kabini
looks down in complete horror at the
state of a destroyed vehicle power still
holding pingasy hostage demands that
quan she leave her and denchi alone
quanchi politely asks power to stand
down promising her safety which causes
her to hesitate suddenly our boy beam
emerges from the floor knocking back
long and freeing dingy from her grasp as
denji chooses to flee kwon shi is
stopped by yushida who requests a
rematch
the two begin to spa rapidly dodging one
another's blows but still landing a few
solid hits on one another yoshida
comments that quan shi is likely not
human due to her minimal reaction to
several devastating blows meanwhile
dingy and beam flee with beam advising
him not to waste blood by turning into
his chainsaw form
as they run denji accidentally stands on
tolka's nail and is suddenly whisked
into the air as they both react with
shock and confusion dingy is ripped
apart by the cursed devil before tolker
appears and kicks bean to the ground as
denji and beam lay unconscious the woman
appears and applauds tulku's work
however ignoring tulka's concerns of
moving the body the woman begins to
explain the secrets of making a perfect
doll she says by gathering the trust
respect worship and pity of an
individual over a period of time before
converting them you can make the perfect
doll with that she then transforms him
revealing that she in fact is the real
santa claus and that that elderly man
was merely another perfect doll
controlled by her as aki and the other
hunters awaken kuan shi best yoshida and
throws him through a window as he falls
he is able to catch himself with the
octopus devil back inside the others
prepare to fight until aki suddenly
stops horrified and confused by his
future vision from outside santa claus
sacrifices the elderly man and three
children that he had promised to the
hell devil in return for sending every
living person within the building to
hell those inside the building are all
of a sudden plunged into pitch-black
darkness as those outside are horrified
to see a giant six-fingered hand reach
down and seemingly crush the building
those who are inside the building then
quickly appear in a large grassy field
with the sky completely covered in
thousands of various doors all moving
throughout the air this is hell
as the group surveyed their surroundings
in hell aki kicks denshi awake
immediately dingy reactivatedly begins
to transform but is only able to make
the tip of the chainsaw appear from his
head due to the fact that he is low on
blood kwon she requests their truce
among the various parties whilst they
try to figure out their current
situation she turns and notes that the
fiends power long pingasty and violence
are all suffering nervous breakdowns aki
asks the angel devil of their current
situation to which angel in an
absolutely petrified daze explains that
they are in hell
quan shi asks pingasty if they have
means of an escape however pingasy
frightenly explains that they are being
watched by devils were they power far
greater than that of the gun devil the
primal fears whom have never died
in desperation pingasy asks permission
to commit suicide only to weep as she is
refused by quan she she cries out as one
of the doors opens and a black drop of
liquid falls out towards the ground
as it does so it symbols the entrance of
the darkness devil the group ready
themselves to fight and as darkness
surrounds them a row of bisected
astronauts appear and a moment quicker
than light itself the darkness devil
moves past them all detaching each and
every single arm from all of their
bodies each person reacts with shock
falling to the ground and bleeding from
their exposed wounds as tulka now fully
under santa clause's control offers the
darkness devil a proposition
denji's heart in return for the power to
kill makima
now flashing outside of hell santa claus
receives a small fragment of the
darkness devil's flesh then proceeds to
swallow it whole as the darkness devil
accepts santa claus's deal it picks up
tolka and rips him apart kusukabe
attempts to utilize the stone devil's
power to fight however the darkness
devil merely grabs the stone devil and
crushes it killing kusakawe while this
happens beam using blood from his
severed arms revives dingy before being
split into pieces by the darkness devil
and killed like
i'm being followed i'm freaking serious
here
you're about to lose it
same beam's corpse quan shi and tamaoki
prepare to attack however are also
mutilated alongside power long and
pinasty bro
seeing this the petrified violence fiend
asks kabini to remove his mask he then
attacks with a kick however before he
can hit the darkness devil it speaks in
an unknown language and his body is
blasted with multiple holes dingy now
transformed then lunges to attack but
before he can make contact all of his
bones are crushed and snapped which
makes him crumple to the ground as aki
observes power's unconscious body he is
reminded of amino and collapses
muttering i
not again i
still alive the violence vein attacks
once more but is impaled by a sick
ass-looking renaissance blade on
steroids that are suddenly summoned by
the darkness devil as the fiend's blood
reigns down the darkness devil crouches
looming over archie as the angel devil
looks on too scared to even move the
darkness devil slowly turns to look at
him he then randomly begins to bleed
from his eyes nose and mouth before
collapsing to the floor ahi likewise
begins to bleed as the darkness devil
reaches out to touch him suddenly prince
appears grabbing at the darkness devil
but like all of the others before she
can make contact she too is absolutely
dominated quickly communicating with
machima though prince is ordered to
summon her to hell what she tries to
stop but make him a command to her she
follows these orders and makima emerges
both her and the darkness devil then
face each other quickly snapping their
fingers in each other's directions
makima's finger suddenly snaps as the
various mouths of the darkness devil
erupt with blood makima approaches
tulka's body placing her hand on his
decapitated head then holding her arm
out her bones are slowly twisted and
cracked as the darkness devil summons a
sword to impale her as making the
touches his head tolker offers all of
himself to the hell devil in return for
sending them all back
just then as quickly as they all entered
they are all transported back to the
rooftop of the theme park santa claus
was stationed at as this happens santa
claus absorbs her remaining dolls
transforming into a tall multi-armed
creature she begins to approach makima
taunting her while makima holds denji's
torso and now having given him some of
her blood pulls his cord
she then explains that with the darkness
there was flesh no attacks and the dark
will have any effect on her however
makima asks dingy if he will save her to
which he responds having transformed
with an aggressive woof before charging
into battle kishibe and yoshida sit
outside finishing off the remaining
dolls they discuss makima and
acknowledge that she has some ulterior
motivations to her actions beyond that
of the bureau as kishibe asks whether
she can hear them yoshida explains that
she currently isn't as none of her
subservients are nearby going on to say
that she can only borrow the ears of
lower life forms such as rats or birds
back on the rooftop denji slices through
santa claus's arm angrily yelling at her
about placing power and the others in
danger moving through a shadow santa
claus is able to instantaneously heal
herself and blast dingy through the
floor dingy gets up lunging at her but
is knocked back by another swarm of
dolls sugar huggy looks on while
clutching kwon she's seven head then
removing her eye patch and reaching
inside of the socket she yanks out a
long arrow-like blade before dropping
the head into the swarm attacking denji
the dolls are suddenly torn apart as
kwonji appears revived in her hybrid
form proving that she also wasn't human
kwanji agrees to fight alongside denji
in order to avenge long and pinasty
before suddenly vanishing over in a
nearby alleyway kwon shi appears in
front of santa claus blasting her with
powerful bolts however just as quickly
as she is torn apart she heals herself
and congratulates quan shi on her
moniker as the first devil hunter
wondering how to attack quan she whom is
moving at speed she cannot register
santa claus suddenly returns the
humanity to her dolls restoring their
minds whilst forcing them to continue
the assault as dingy stares at the now
frightened and screaming human dolls
charging towards him he exasperately
shouts there's some real villain [__]
right there now faced with the emotional
human dolls then she chooses to run away
but his attempts to escape are blocked
and he is forced to impale one of the
dolls with his chainsaw feeling guilty
over this denji holds back allowing the
other dolls to gradually swarm him
suddenly kwon shi appears shooting the
remaining dolls to pieces she tells
denji that their dolls are merely
imitating humans then she asks how sure
she is to what she responds that
believing it is the only way he'll be
able to bring himself to kill them
reminding him their ignorance is bliss
taking this moment to pause santa claus
bursts through a wall and grabs quan she
however is once again torn apart by her
blasts looking up quan she realizes that
night has fallen with her newfound
darkness enhancing santa claus's powers
even further santa claus moves forward
and hits dingy towards the gas station
whilst grabbing the various bullets
fired by quan shi out of the air quan
she turns saying that santa claus has
turned along and pingasy's corpses into
dolls and taken sugar hagie hostage
unable to bring herself to fight them
quan shi is stabbed through the chest by
the pingasty doll which causes santa
claus to wonder whether she could turn
kwon shi into a doll as well
suddenly denji emerges coasting himself
and gasoline then revving his chainsaws
together he creates a spark igniting
himself on fire leaping towards a
surprise santa claus he begins to tear
into her body as she lets out a series
of pained cries
dengi and santa claus both writhe in
pain as dingy complains about the heat
of his flaming body pushing him back
santa claus heals herself instantly
mocking dingy for his foolishness dingy
retorts claiming to watch a great amount
of educational programming before
revealing the chain of his chainsaw to
be wrapped around santa claus's body
using it to keep himself close he lunges
again slicing into her she comments on
the futility of his actions as she
splits the pain and damage between her
various dolls however dingy comments
that her regeneration has begun to slow
due to the light from his flames
suddenly santa claus slams dingy into a
wall as a numerous number of dolls break
through and begin stabbing him in the
back santa claus then chooses to wait
and watch dingy burn and die from blood
loss calling him machima's dog however
dingy instead tears into the dolls and
drinks their blood to rejuvenate himself
he tries to move forward only to once
again be swarmed by dolls as santa
mockingly tells him that he will be
reunited with makima in death suddenly
denji begins to pull on his chain
dragging santa claus towards him as he
ignores the blows from countless dolls
around him growing more worried santa
claus orders her dolls to keep her away
from him pulling against the chain and a
tug of war a pair of dolls and a car
then comes speeding around the corner
slamming into dingy and causing a
massive explosion but still denji
emerges from the wreckage cloaked
entirely in flames having not stopped
pulling on the chain
in shock and horror santa claus
questions the extent of his power and
denji proudly reveals his motivation to
still be going on the holiday with
mahima hoisting santa claus into the ear
denji flings her towards himself before
tearing through her and ripping her body
to pieces as she begins to reform then
she grabs the remains of the burning car
and slams them down on her causing a
second explosion which rips through her
body turning her into nothing but a
smoldering mess
as dingy heals himself with some of the
doll's blood santa begins threatening
him revealing that she has armies of
dolls stationed across the entire planet
and along with the power of the darkness
devil will be able to hunt him and
everyone he cares about forever making
his life a living hell
but dingy cockingly reminds her of his
immortality before he is suddenly and
surprisingly decapitated by quan she
kwon shi then asks cosmo to use her
power on santa claus because while the
conflicts had been going on she was just
wandering around the city on her own
waiting for this moment flashing to
within her own mind santa claus suddenly
awakens standing inside an endless
library she sees cosmo sitting at a
nearby table and comments on the
futility of using psychological attacks
against her due to her mind being linked
to dolls across the world cosmo looking
up introduces herself as the cosmos
theme before explaining the extent of
her power the ability to grant
individuals total and complete
understanding of everything in the
universe a process so overwhelming that
the victim is forced into a
semi-conscious state where they are only
able to process the word halloween over
and over again until their death as
santa claus suddenly finds herself
falling through the library her body is
shown in the real world crumbling to
dust as it mutters the word halloween
over and over
yoshida and kishibe then arrive as
kwanshi turns to fight them silently
though the two put on blindfolds and
makima emerges from between them holding
a sword seeing this quan she instantly
surrenders offering makima anything in
return for sparing the lives of her
underlings makima doesn't even listen to
her though and ignores their plays
before quickly slicing all three of
their heads off in one swoop elsewhere a
news anchor reports on the dole station
throughout the world who have been
locked into saying halloween as a result
of the cosmos fiend's power amongst them
aldo is seen also shuffling around and
repeating halloween with an obvious pain
in his eyes
back at the main location yoshida
removes his blindfold questioning why
kishibe doesn't want to do the same to
which he simply replies that he doesn't
want to see a damn
thing after the battle now and back at
home dingy awakes with power lying
across his chest he's then greeted by
aki who is making breakfast dingy
comments on powers screaming throughout
the night before mentioning aki's arm
aki informs him that he was lucky as
angel had lost both of his arms by the
way if you didn't notice the arms that
the darkness devil cuts off spells out
mahima whilst obviously sadly beam and
the violence theme both died and kabini
actually resigned this time randomly
then power begins screaming dingy tries
restraining her as she attempts to claw
into her own mouth out of fear of the
darkness devil hiding inside of it
clutching dingy she now begins to cry
with just pure fear of the darkness
devil but hey at least power is still
alive out of everyone so far like
honestly i was heartbroken when i saw
beam and all the other guys get turned
into darkness sushi but at least power
and aki are still alive at the moment
anyway a short while later as they all
eat breakfast and power struggles to
keep her food down aki comments on how
makima is still deciding to continue her
trip in a flashback mahima and dingy
share a meal while discussing the
aftermath of the conflict part way
through the conversation makima invites
dingy on a trip with her to which he
reacted with intense excitement yet he
suddenly stopped when he remembered
power in the states she is currently in
back in the present aki asks why he
didn't ultimately choose to go but dingy
simply responds that he isn't even
certain throughout the day power
interrupts denji at awkward moments
constantly asking him to check for the
darkness devil hiding in various
locations this work pays off though for
our boy as he gets in there and power
actually asks him to take a bath with
her but of course only for protection
from the darkness devil and random
japanese fashion i guess the two shower
and then hop into a bath afterwards like
my mum would actually kill me if i did
that [__] here now in the bath dingy is
surprised that despite the intimacy of
their act it doesn't feel weird nearing
bed now aki suggests sleeping in shifts
in order to look after power that night
power wakes stingy quietly begging him
to not hate her for making him miss his
trip and in return she offers to let him
drink her blood as repayment though
dingy is initially uninterested power
begins to shout and cry resulting in him
giving in as he begins to drink the
blood from her neck in a kind of like
sexual manner
he thinks of pochisa and what makima had
told him yet now despite having a close
intimate relationship with power none of
the actions they do feel romantic at all
concluding that there are some things
that one is better off not knowing or
understanding dingy thinks back to the
door and his nightmares resolving to
keep it close
please open the door man i want to see
what's behind it surely it's just
pachita's house aki informs dingy and
power of his plans to visit hokkaido
denji and power both protest about being
left behind since their previous trip
was cancelled aki eventually gives in
and the trio leave meowi with kashibe
the dedicated kaduri after one literally
terrible journey for aki the three are
seen moving on foot towards the grave
did you empower throw snowballs at archi
which is obviously super reminiscent for
him if you think about the dude's little
bro and how him and denji have like kind
of over time developed to be almost
brothers in a way since they first met
after arriving at his family grave arki
begins to pray noting denji and powell's
disappearance he then sees them eating
rotten offerings left on their graves
suddenly power vomits up their food
before screaming that it was a plot by
the darkness devil
later at an inn while they eat dinner
powell complains about the amount of
vegetables throwing them to the others
before realising that there is little
food left for herself instead she takes
dingy's arm and bites into it drinking
his blood and causing another argument
that night dingy awakes to see aki
sitting looking out of the window at the
snow as he joins him aki comments that
he visits the grave each year and is
usually miserable but funnily enough the
two of them managed to keep him
distracted the entire time
back in tokyo now kishibe returns meowi
to aki kishibe then comments on the
difficulties of controlling dingy in
power but aki responds that the pair
have actually matured a lot he then asks
kashibo whether division 4 could be
removed from the gun devil hunt which
surprises kishibe he then tries to
remind him of the safety precautions
being taken as well as the fact that the
mission will be classified meaning aki
may never hear of its outcome unless he
is directly involved baraki still agrees
which causes a confused kishibe to ask
why he changed his mind and aki thinks
back to seeing dingy and powers
unconscious and injured bodies in hell
before responding i got cold feet that
evening ahi returns home to see denji
and power preparing dinner for him
noting a strange purple root within it
dingy comments that power likely added
some unknown secret ingredients as they
too boast on their meal aki takes a bite
before instantly vomiting power happily
calls the dish a catastrophe as dingy
comments on the fact that all three of
them now have vomited from it now lying
on the beard together aki comments on
power's calmness and the lack of
screaming power considers this before
responding that she may have defeated
the darkness devil in hell to which
dingy casually agrees as they wash the
dishes they suddenly receive a phone
call summoning them to the bureau
messing with makima she informs the
group that while she has taken aki and
the rest of division iv of the gun devil
mission denji and power are still
required to go she asks aki to leave if
he does not intend to join them dingy
agrees to the mission followed by power
who wishes to continue working nice and
close with denji troubled aki asks to
rejoin the mission to which makima
swiftly agrees honestly i think making
was kind of playing archie right now i
don't know what's going on here having
already begun the operation makima then
details the current status of the gun
devil explaining that it had already
been defeated and confined denji and aki
respond with utter shock as makima
explains it was found dead shortly after
its initial attack before being split
into various fragments aki asks about
the guns used previously against the
devil hunters only for mahima to reveal
that they were created by man she
elaborates explaining that though there
is an official global ban on firearms
each government secretly manufactures
and circulates guns on their black
markets in doing so the remaining
fragments of the gun devil are given
more power hearing this aki realizes
that in order to destroy the gun devil
the bureau will need to go against the
wishes of every global superpower mahima
calmly agrees calling the plan a kind of
war
outside dingy and power questioned
arki's despondence still believing the
mission to be about simply killing the
gun devil ahi explains that even after
they killed the gun devil their body
would merely be collected by the
japanese government continuing the cycle
of the global hostilities whilst also
meaning the gun devil is immortal denji
expresses confusion believing that the
gun devil must be mortal or else mahima
would not have promised him a wish in
return for killing it suddenly aki is
given a vision of the future by the
future devil reacting with sudden and
intense fear that night alone aki
summons the future devil asking about
the vision the future devil explains
that it is a mere and unavoidable future
one in which archi and power are
slaughtered by dingy
followed by the arrival of the devils
that devils fear most so yeah here we go
guys let's get into that part of the
story where it's gonna get real well now
i think sometime in the next few days
aki visits angel and explains his future
vision to him angel asks why he is being
informed given that the vision is
supposedly unavoidable aki explains that
with the loss of both of his arms there
is a possibility the bureau will put
angel down
as such hen kishibe wrote a letter of
recommendation angel questions aki's
devil-hating reputation but aki suddenly
informs him of their plan to hunt the
gun devil and that they may never see
one another again angel stops him
explaining that the humans whose
lifespan he's absorbed often haunt his
nightmares and offers to do whatever he
can to prevent aki's death so that the
same doesn't happen with him he then
suggests that they both go and ask
makima for advice
as they walk angels suggest he run away
and leave his life with the bureau
behind in order to prevent his own death
but aki refuses citing denji power and
mahima as reasons to stay
surprised by his mentioning of makima
angel comments on aki's feelings for her
and as the peers spot makima aki also
quietly begins to wonder why exactly he
actually likes her aki asks why she's
there to which she responds that she was
simply waiting
aki then explains his vision and desire
to keep power and denji safe blaming
himself for his brother's death he asks
the same be prevented with them and
promises to make any contract with any
devil to do so
hearing this makima looks him in the eye
before asking him to make a contract
with her
aki reacts with shock as makima repeats
herself now commanding him to accept the
contract as the angel devil looks on he
slowly begins to remember the beach as
the location where he was first found by
mahima he gradually remembers a
community of people who took him in
before focusing on a young woman from
his previous memory remembering her as
the one i loved and the one who loved me
then he remembers mahima arriving on the
beach and asking to see his powers
though he refused she demanded ordering
him to use them hours later he then
reawoke having absorbed the lives of
everyone in the village damn honestly
this one hurt like it's real super sad
to realize the cool introduction angel
had actually
had an extremely sad beginning like he
murked an entire village but that
village was his family and he was merely
controlled by makima snapping back to
the present angel reacts with horror as
he sees aki now accepting mahima's
contract he begins to yell out to makima
and as she turns to look at him she
comments on how he must have just
regained his memories instantly using 10
years of life force to create a dope ass
blade the angel devil lunges at makima
in an attempt to cut her head off
however just before the blade nears her
throat she merely says the word down and
the angel devil crumples to the floor
impressed that he had managed to break
free of her power making me kneels next
to him ordering the devil to give his
all to her to which he agrees then
apologizing to the two of them mahima
explains that she had no other choice
due to the massive amount of spies
within the japanese bureau the hunt for
the gun devil was always a bluff planned
to fail hiding her ulteria plan
one in which will occur the greatest
amount of damage worldwide flashing away
to the goddamn united states of america
hell yeah westerners let's go
there the president while on the phone
to probably the other members of
congress states that the time has come
because of the duty he must try to
uphold when every other nation has just
accepted utter defeat he makes a
contract with the gun devil one in which
he offers one year of the lifespan of
all citizens across the entire continent
of the united states of america in
return for the death of mahima the
control devil so yeah i think that
explains a lot back in japan as the
church bells ring and the choir of
children sing mahima incites the gun
devil telling it to come on september 12
1997 the gun devil appears in japan once
it appears it activates a flurry of
abilities instantly fire a bullet
through the head of every male within a
thousand meters confirmed activate
second ability fire a bullet through
children's aged 0-12 within 1500 meters
confirmed literally decimating
everything within its vicinity as it
slowly reveals the true scope of the gun
devil a few seconds before the gun devil
arrived a young boy was planning to go
play soccer with his friends he heads
out of the door but one second later the
city he is in is obliterated by the gun
devil's presence as it makes its way
towards makima another second passes and
at 500 kilometers makima cites the
gandival continuing to move forward
towards a direction at ridiculous speeds
multiple examples of devastation are
shown with peaceful cities turned into
complete devastation cars flipped and
countless thousands instantly killed by
the fallout as another second passes the
gun devil activates his ability to fire
a bullet through the heart of every
living thing born on specific months
throughout the year within a one
kilometer radius exactly four seconds
after its first appearance the gun devil
stops and then activates another ability
and starts beaming its bullets in
makima's direction
one second later makima prepares her
ability but is shot through the head
making her 29th recorded death as
expected though she immediately recovers
as her brain meta forms into a freaking
halo around her head not gonna lie this
panel here is so freaking fire man it's
so cool some of these panels recently
i've just been losing it i've been
creaming everywhere anyways one more
second later the gun devil again stops
as in front of him makima stands with
the bodies of prince sawatari aki angel
kuros nintendo who are all shown to be
attached to her with a chain
someone summoning the combined power of
all of their devil contracts a sudden
hole opens up in the sky above the gun
devil as a swarm of unknown creatures
descend wielding blades flashing away
from probably what is the gun devil
getting absolutely stunted on over at
their apartment then she hears a knock
on the door and goes to answer it
however as he reaches for the handle he
sees a vision of his nightmare as
pachita's words echo through his head
telling him to not open the door
as the pounding on the door continues
denji is interrupted by the phone
suddenly ringing on the other end mahima
who is being a freaking ho like stuff
her man i bet this was her plan all
along to kill beam and hell plus what is
going down right now it's all just so
suspect she quickly explains to dingy
that the gun devil had appeared without
warning and then failed to defeat it and
because of that it has taken over a dead
body and escaped going on to say that
it's the gun devil at the door mahima
then commands denji to not think about
anything while he fights even still
despite this call both dingy and power
are skeptical believing the person at
the door knocking to be aki coming home
from the mission
yet as denji approaches the door he
can't help but seem to grow more and
more hesitant because of this he tells
power to leave with meowi from the
balcony just in case it actually is the
devil dingy still uncertain thinking
that possibly makima might even be
playing a prank opens the door sadly
revealing the reanimated corpse of aki
who is now morphed into and is
controlled by the gun devil
dingy not recognizing it though
awkwardly asks whether the two must
fight now however the devil simply
raises the gun and says denji's name
which causes denji to wonder how the gun
devil even knows his name in a different
perspective we find ourselves inside of
arki's mind ahi looking at his hand
finds a snowball and realizes he must
have been having a snowball fight with
denji yet in reality each snowball
thrown by aki translates to a massively
destructive gun blast in the real world
completely leveling dingy's floor of the
building having fallen from the building
now dingy finds himself torn in half by
the blast even still he commands power
to flee as the two come to the
realization that the creature is arky
suddenly arki's gun devil leaps from the
building at breakneck speed in an
attempt to kill power yet our freaking
boy ain't letting power die yet as he
manages to transform in time to block
the attack
now in arki's fantasy power has also
joined with aki telling power that she's
on dingy's team then as he begins to
fang his snowballs at the two it flashes
back to the real world to show the
complete devastation as aki sends both
power and denji flying back noticing a
pair of bystanders aki turns and points
his machinery at them asking if they
also want to play with him instantly he
vaporizes them though with a smile on
his face as denji begins to attack and
slice into him aki only views this as
dingy playfully throwing snowballs right
back at him the battle escalates with
every blast by aki quickly leveling
massive amounts of the surrounding area
sending cars flying and murdering
countless civilians though dingy
attempts to protect some his efforts are
largely fruitless as the majority of
everyone he saves later gets hurt they
continue fighting with aki's smile
growing wider and wider with each blast
dingy screams out for aki to stop and
return back to normal yaki's fantasy
self can't hear anything he is saying
and in aki's reality he can only see the
smile on his brother dingy's face
seeing his smile he comments on how for
the first time he's having fun as his
parents never really paid any attention
to him but now his life actually seems
like fun as he says this denji is both
hit in the gut by the snowball and in
reality by a catastrophic shock knocking
him to the floor while lucky's fantasy
continues he asks the child dingy if
he's giving up but as he begins to stand
back up he thinks he's ready for another
round of snowball fighting in the real
world though arkey continues his
onslaught repeatedly blasting dingy
backwards denji attempts to defend
himself but because he is unwilling to
hurt aki he's forced to simply beg for
him to turn back this is like some next
level obi so versus kakashi type battle
right now it's like the crossover of
childhood to
to adult type thing i'm just loving it
like it's so
sad but good and odds just this arc is
actually fantastic man suddenly aki lets
off a massive blast sending digi flying
back through multiple buildings causing
him to lose one arm and both legs while
dingy lies crippled in the ruins of a
building slowly a crowd of onlookers
gather around him a woman approaches
pulling out a knife before suddenly
stabbing her own hand and asking him to
save them each bystander then does the
same and gives dengi blood and begs for
him to defeat the devil and save them
all with the city now in complete and
utter tatters the gun devil slowly makes
his way towards denji meanwhile during
aki's dream denji begins biffing
snowballs back with insane force though
aki is initially excited by this he
quickly notes then she is crying and is
fantasy so in order to stop this aki
admits defeat simply falling back onto
the ground and saying that he doesn't
like snowball fights anyway because they
just get your hands cold
when he looks back up he notices that
dingy has gone and he is instead
replaced by his younger brother taiyo
who's running back from the house with
the balls and gloves he went to grab
earlier on in this series damn it always
hits real hard that power right there in
reality though it is revealed that in
order to stop his onslaught then she had
stabbed aki with his chainsaws killing
him as dingy returns to his human form
in shock at what had just happened the
future devil appears on a nearby roof
and laughs commenting on how aki
hayakawa died in the worst way possible
for the chainsaw boy
yeah damn man that's like truly the
worst possible diff uh dingy right there
i could possibly imagine
i can't even right now it's such a crazy
ass [__] uh that was actually amazing
after receiving the money from archie's
will dingy and power rent a smaller
apartment with a lovely view then spend
the rest on delicious food and video
games one night dingy goes out to grab
an ice cream and also a rice ball for
power after purchasing some he sits on a
bench and finishes it then noting the
word winner on the ice cream stick he
thinks the words i killed arki and
immediately vomits
laying down now he thinks of how he has
constantly felt confused and unhappy
since aki's death he begins to speak to
pochita but before he can say anything
makima appears touching his hands and
telling him that his hands are cold she
tells him to stand up then she complies
still in a confused saddened state over
his brother's death makima then invites
stingy to her apartment for some tea to
warm up now they're inviting dingy
inside the two are instantly swarmed
with a mini cute ass pier doggos makima
briefly pampers the dogs pissing them
and talking to them excitedly before
going on to ask dingy what kind of tea
he'd like as she continues to dote on
her dogs with treats and adorable belly
rubs dingy watching her thinks on how
much calmer and happier he feels he
thanks her for it and she begins to pet
him makima then reminds dingy that she
had offered him any one wish for
defeating the gun devol after
considering what he wants for a moment
dingy sadly states that he wants to be
treated as one of her dogs
sitting there mahima asks dingy to
elaborate on his desire to which he
explains that he no longer wishes to
think for himself as the growth of
relationships and responsibilities in
his life has led to an overwhelming
amount of grief and regret in his
decisions as such he feels placing all
of his decisions in makima's hands will
allow him to live a relaxed guiltless
life makima asks him if he is certain of
his choice with injury responding with a
half-hearted thumbs up not gonna lie
this was the moment i realized that my
boy goddamn messed up real bad here like
i paused and honestly did not want to
scroll my screen down for the next few
minutes while reading this part just an
absolute anticipation of what this
absolute hoe was about to do to our
boy's heart anyway anyway the control
freak test her new authority by asking
genji to perform several dog-like tricks
to which denji follows age and is pit on
the head as a reward he thinks of how
happy he is suddenly there is a knock at
the door makima reveals that she had
invited power earlier on then she asks
why however makima reminds him not to
think denji responds with a wolf and
makima guides him to the front door then
orders him to open it so that she can
kill power denji responds with another
wolf before pausing in sudden confusion
makima continues guiding denji to the
door as he blusters and asks her if
she's joking she ignores his hesitation
as she once again orders him to open the
door slowly denji moves towards the
handle thinking about how power would be
holding a cake on the other side as he
opens the door he questions why he
assumed she'd be holding a cake before
remembering the next day was in fact his
birthday looking into the corridor he
sees power standing in the hallway
holding a cake before either having time
to react makima points her finger at
power and says the word bang
power's torso is completely obliterated
then she looks on in shock and silence
as power's head falls between her legs
onto the floor mahima takes stingy's
hand telling him they are cold again and
ordering him back inside then she begins
to sweat profusely as he asks to speak
but no words will come out mahima closes
the door on power's body and leads dingy
back to the couch still in shock dingy
shakily asks magima if he is in a dream
makima leans over to rest her head on
his lap before she begins laughing
hysterically
honestly this freaking panel here she's
such a home man i saw this panel months
before i even started reading chainsaw
man and i just assumed that this was
going to be a happy moment like i think
anyone would think just looking at this
panel like it looks super happy from an
outside perspective but now after
actually getting the context around the
situation i'm just mortified at the pure
evilness of this damn witch and also you
guys ready for this revelation markyman
demands that dingy take off his shirt
hesitating she reminds him of his
subservience and he proceeds lying back
down on his lap she begins to speak
playing with dingy's cord as she does so
she explains that dingy's promise to
bachita was in fact a contract desiring
to break that contract mahima explains
she set about giving him everything he
wanted before snatching it away
she explains that by giving him food a
job and a family she would allow him to
attain a new level of normalcy before
destroying it she then informs him that
any happiness of normalcy he experiences
from then on will be orchestrated by her
with the express purpose of eventually
destroying it when dingy asks why she
says that the time has come for you to
atone for your sins
elaborating mahima explains that she
looked into denji's past and saw his
repressed memories the hidden ones
behind the door that bachita ordered him
not to open she explains that denji had
the actual truth from himself in order
to be able to live a normal life the
truth was that he actually murdered his
father she goes on further stating that
then she killed his abusive and
alcoholic father in self-defense and
that the claims of suicide were merely
created by the mafia so that denji would
inherit his debts mahima tells denji
that by opening the door and accepting
his past he had accepted that he was
unworthy of a normal happy life she
reminds him that the same occurred with
aki and power though dingy was warned
not to and the other options were
available he ultimately opened the door
and accepted their deaths
makima kneels down and asks the child
like dingy whether he believes he
deserves a normal life with him sadly
responding no
now flashing forward to the next morning
everything seems normal as making
mccalmie eats breakfast and dingy lies
motionless on her couch she then gets
dressed and guides denshi outside into
the corridor there a number of demons
many of whom are dingy's deceased allies
kneel in front of them mahima explains
that they were all followers of the
chainsaw devil whom put their lives on
their line to protect it waiting for the
day of resurrection as she says this the
building is suddenly breached by a devil
hunter group named the anti-machima
squad led by the old lovable fart
kishibe mahima is gunned down and killed
as a number of devil hunters slip their
throats in order to suddenly summon the
hell devil who they ask to kill makima
and banish her to hell however hearing
this makima commands dingy to save her
which causes his intestines to burst out
of his chest and throttle him as the
hunters slowly die outside the building
the hell devil emerges now in a flaming
central-like form dingy standing atop
the corpses of the anti-machima squad
pulls his cord and transforms into the
chainsaw devil in an instant he leaps
outside slicing the hell devil into many
clean cut pieces of hell shishimi as the
blood and guts rain down he stands tall
in a darker more muscular form with
multiple arms and blades spawning from
him like honestly i freaking love this
berserk level body armor that he's got
on right now it looks so freaking badass
fujimoto is actually a base when it
comes to drawing this kind of like dirty
stuff if you know what i mean that's
just how i feel right now it's so dirty
and grimy it's so clean dingy stands
above the decapitated hell level as one
of the devil hunters gives blood to
revive it as he does a door opens above
them and the hell devil's hand emerges
crushing dingy like a bug transporting
them to hell from a nearby building
makima watches commenting on the outcome
to kishibe who now has a gun pointed at
her head makima notes that shooting her
would be useless as she has a deal with
the prime minister of japan to transfer
all of the damage taken by her to a
random japanese citizen hence how she
has managed to revive each time so far
that she has died asking why she remains
calm even with the chainsaw devil being
cast into hell makima responds that it
will return to save her kashibe in
horror asks mahima what she truly is to
which she responds she's a fan of the
chainsaw devil as she talks the chainsaw
devil tears through various devils in
hell she explains that within hell the
chainsaw man is known as the hero of
hell when it hears a cry for help the
chainsaw devil moves in eviscerating
every devil it faces friend or foe
mahima then explains the ultimate power
of the chainsaw devil any devil consumed
by it has their names erased from
existence faced against such an
unstoppable opponent all other devils
either despise fear or worship the
chainsaw devil so this x actually goes
explain i guess why bean was such a
fanboy as he literally worshipped the
chainsaw devil and i love you being rest
in peace brother anyway kishibe
expresses doubt that such a power could
even exist however mahima retorts by
asking him what he knows of the
holocaust it is then revealed that
kishibe alongside humanity at large have
no knowledge of nazism could help japan
always bringing up the 40s like it's
just yesterday mahima continues
explaining that almost every major
crisis faced by humanity will all erase
from existence by the chainsaw devil she
goes on to explain that even universal
constants such as humanity's sixth sense
and the four possible conclusions other
than death which honestly i have no idea
what that is someone who's like into
that culture or something let me know
down in the comment section below at the
end of life we're also erased mahima
elaborates explaining that she cannot
even remember these things though she
remembers the fights between their
devils and the chainsaw devil kishibe
asks mahima's intentions with the devil
to which she reveals the true nature of
her own ability to control any being
that she believes is lesser than herself
therefore if she were able to defeat the
chainsaw devil in combat she would be
able to control it and use its powers to
create a world without pain war or death
kishibe asks what she would do if she
lost to which she replies that she is a
fan of the chainsaw devil and it would
be a happy honorable end turning back to
the window mahima notes dingy's return
as the door to hell reopens and the
chainsaw devil emerges showered in blood
khasheba continues the standoff with
mahima as he stares her down she wants
him to stand back as she turns to
prepare to face dingy in an instant then
she bursts through the wall and slices
much him into pieces before turning and
looking to kashibe suddenly dingy hears
someone somewhere say their words save
me and immediately leaves elsewhere at a
burger restaurant a group of employees
sing and dance to an irritated customer
kabini now an employee there delivers
the food to their table attempting to
dance along awkwardly she is taken aside
by her boss who chastises her for her
forced smile and verbal tick of saying
ah as other employees join in kabini
quietly mutters the words save me the
staff suddenly turn to see denji looming
over them greeting kabini with var the
customer attempts to flee but is
instantly decapitated by denji then she
looks at the restaurant's menu and
remembers an earlier request to pachita
to try hamburgers since he added a
nearby table he attempts to order a
hamburger speaking through a series of
chainsaw revs the restaurant's mascot is
decapitated as he attempts to contact
the devil hunters suddenly deciphering
denji's revs kabini and the other
employees begin to prepare his order as
they sing and dance with panic on their
faces then she moves his arms shuffling
in time with their dancing kabini is
ordered to deliver the food to his table
however as she does she trips and spills
the food all over him looking up at the
annoyed dingy kabini asks for another
hamburger as the employees repeat their
dance now with tears streaming down
their faces kabini's boss begins to
shout at her blaming her for their
demise before he is too decapitated as
kabini again attempts to deliver the
order she trips and falls spilling the
food identically to the first time as
she lays on the floor terrified she
begins screaming her disbelieving
co-workers begin to accuse denchi of
playing an elaborate televised prank
instantly though he is decapitated as
kabini begins to pick up the ingredients
off the floor and reconstruct the burger
dingy takes a bite before grimacing with
disapproval remembering another past
wish of danjis to go on a date with a
girl he grabs kabini and carries her
outside then stopping in an ice cream
van dingy shreds it to pieces before
acquiring a pair of ice creams for the
two of them kabini continues to sob
crying out that the ice cream doesn't
taste of anything a devil hunter then
appears and threatens dingy but is
instantly eviscerated as denji turns
kabini towards a dance dance revolution
machine and orders her to dance after
commenting that she has no money then
she then shreds an atm and kabini begins
to play out of fear as she continues
dancing dingy actually leaves he then
arrives on top of a rooftop and
surveying her surroundings notices
makima is nearby she comments on him
noticing her as she commands her allies
to emerge suddenly denji stands
surrounded by seven devil hunters all
commenting on their love for makima and
desire to date her as the first full
wager a date with mahima for killing
dingy the other three are revealed to be
katana man rezay and kwan shi they all
each pledge their allegiance to makima
with the katana man commenting that she
has saved their lives over and over
again as makima agrees to the bet a date
in return for killing dng
which is you know like a complete role
reversal of what was going on with denji
earlier on so i absolutely love that i
think it's quite cool quirky and why not
as machima stands amongst her group of
human devil hybrids she elaborates on
their true nature they are not humans
devils or fiends but another type of
creature that was erased by the chainsaw
devil's powers yet still somehow
continues to exist she explains that
whilst fighting them in hell the
chainsaw devil disappeared and appeared
on earth as pochita and they have been
searching for him since
as denji yawns makima commands her
agents to attack each agent pulls out
their weapon transforming themselves
into their hybrid forms and lunging at
dingy as each makes contact with him
they are blown back by the force of him
leaping forward crashing through
skyscrapers while slicing through quan
xi and the broadsword hybrid as they
land in an apartment complex dingy
kneels over kwonji's tatted body
clutching his severed heads behind him
the katana man appears attempting to
slice through dingy however he is
unsuccessful as it is shown then she was
able to decapitate him without taking
any damage himself makima looks on
calmly exclaiming that the conflict
appears unwinnable standing on the floor
below denji the flamethrower hybrid
flies into the ceiling causing a massive
explosion to burst through the building
as dingy leaps backwards to the safety
onto another building the whip hybrid
appears and slashes into him her attacks
seem to have little impact however as
rezay blasts through the building and
grabs stingy carrying him up into the
sky flipping mid-air dengue decapitates
rezay before he's impaled by a spear
thrown by the spare hybrid stunned in
mid-air mahima takes the momentary days
to blast injury repeatedly pointing at
him and stating bang as each hit
launches him further and further into
the sky as denji is pushed out of the
atmosphere and into space making the
comments wondering how long he could
hold his breath
reaching inside of himself though dingy
rips out his own heart and flings it
towards the ground as the heart begins
to burn upon re-entry into the
atmosphere denzi's body begins to reform
around it until it is fully formed still
forming dingy launches his chains across
the city grappling onto mahima the whip
flamethrower and spare hybrids then
hoisting them up into the air they each
express a moment of shock before they
are too torn apart by dingy's chainsaws
flashing over to kabini whose dance
dance revolution is coming to an end she
stands tired and sweating atop the
machine before exclaiming that she
happily got a perfect score her head
turns to the side as she looks over
terrified at chainsaw man who's now
sitting atop the step across from kabini
kabini stands confused asking to the air
why she was dancing as makima answers
from above her prompting kabini and
chainsaw man to look up at her sitting
on the roof above makima goes on to
state that in total she has been killed
26 times by chainsaw man and yet she
questioned why it was that he continued
to refuse to eat her the corpse of the
devil hunter whom the chainsaw man had
killed prior begins to move being pulled
up to mahima as a chain from her body
attaches itself to him and joins makima
floating above several dozen other
chained men kabini starts to show denial
saying twice that she had nothing to do
with the current situation before makima
cuts her off saying that she did indeed
have a major role in the current events
currently unfolding and that the fear of
change for man had grown weaker this
prompts kabini to look over at chainsaw
man as blood begins to leak from his
body making mistakes that she liked
humans the same as they like dogs in the
sense that to her they were loyal easily
manageable smart yet stupid and they all
loved her a television show and the
window of a city shop begins
broadcasting the news stating that
chainsaw man had just defeated the gun
devil he goes on to state that the news
of the gun devil's defeat was being met
with a praise and shock across the
entire globe the broadcaster continues
praising denise's ability to get up over
and over again despite his many injuries
and then switches to a woman who's
stating that the chainsaw man was a hero
and a man who explains how dingy had
fought the dole devil's army and thanks
him for allowing to escape a woman yells
into a mic that she had seen him riding
a shark through the streets as he fought
the typhoon devil a woman exclaims that
he had saved her on a train a man states
that dingy had protected him from the
bat devil and finally another woman says
that he had rescued her at every stop as
people are out on the street celebrating
chainsaw man chanting his name the
broadcaster tells watchers to go outside
and see what's happening for themselves
and that everyone should join together
to cheer him on even more which is
obviously hella dope for our boy but at
the same time time dude's getting mad
debuffed right now if you understand
what's going on because with him more
and more blood is showing pooling around
him making mistakes that the humans
cheering him on were eating away at him
and contrasting the power given to him
by all the devils who feared him a chain
angel then appears floating above makima
as she uses his power stating usage 1
000 years summoning a black red spear as
makima asks if kabini has enough
strength to avoid her coming attack
believing that dingy would attempt to
save her a black circle appears in the
ear in front of makima with three large
humanoid figures appearing in the air
around the growing circle at equal
distances the faces of cabani and
chainsaw man are shown bathed in light
as mahima launches the spear at cabine
changel man moves in front of her
pushing her away as the spear passes
through his torso his blood is shown
gushing out of his body as he collapses
face first onto the ground monkey
massage as the crowd continues to cheer
for our ever weakening chainsaw man
skipping away power is shown sleeping on
a mess of blood and organs complaining
as pochita nudges her with its poor she
opens her eyes and turns her head
towards pachito who tells her to wake up
power initially confused quickly makes
the connection that he was pachita
vegeta smiles at her realization before
telling her that he wanted her to save
dingy he tells her that she truly wasn't
dead as she was currently the blood that
dingy had drunk from her before and that
if nothing was done she would soon
disappear pachita asks for her to eat
some of him and revive as a full-fledged
devil to watch our freaking girl like
holy [__] i couldn't live without power
being around any longer happily obliges
as dingy as her best friend back in
reality mahima moves down onto the
ground with around a dozen members of
public safety lined up behind her
chainsaw man begins to get up on his
hands and knees then as he points his
head forwards power suddenly ejects from
his mouth in the form of the blood vein
power laughs as she points towards
makima which causes blood weapons to
suddenly push out from within the bodies
of her and all of the public safety
members power yells that she is the
strongest as a bloodied machima uses
angel's ability to create a sword worth
of a hundred years power then uses a
move she calls thousand terra blood rain
showering mahima with several dozen
blood weapons as they shoot down from
above she gloats and spouts nonsense as
mahima is continually impaled like that
she herself was the first president as
the barrage of weapons stops makima
calls on the zombie devil which appears
behind her and turns the deceased
members of the public safety into
zombies these zombies rush power
grabbing onto her and biting her she
screams out in pain as making the shoots
off her arm with a finger gun makima
asks a bleeding power how she was still
alive with power refusing to answer as
she lunges back grabbing chainsaw man
and proclaiming him as her own makima
asks for power to give her chainsaw man
under the threat of death stating that
she let power be her pet again if she
gave him over
stupidly power fumbles the bag moving
behind chainsaw man and lifting him up
before stating that she had in fact
captured him but cheetah is shown in a
state of shock and confused as power
happily states their glory was all hers
while power stands there gripping denji
makim asks for power to give her chains
for man anu head power looks on her time
with denji thinking back on when they
first met when he first saved her from
the bat devil when they bathed together
and when they gave aki a meal they'd
cook together our queen though defies
that hoe as blood weapons shoot out of
mahima forcing her weak ass to her knees
power runs off with denji screaming and
asking why she was disobeying makima
despite the fact that victory was
impossible she comes across two devil
hunters which call on the mantis devil
one of its arms shooting up from the
ground and slicing her on the side
before she kills the two now stumbling
as a horde of zombies suddenly rain down
upon her we see a young dirty power
running down and stumbling on a road she
looks at her hand reminiscing on her
belief that all lives were equally
trivial that her life and a stranger's
life was nothing to ever be sad over and
that dingy was an exception to that
belief screaming out that dingy couldn't
die in reality a wounded power bleeding
crawls towards an alleyway dragging
chainsaw man along with her power slowly
moves closer to the dumpster crawling
inside as she realizes the reason she
actually cared about dingy's life was
because he was her first ever friend
a human dingy and theme power are shown
on the dumpster together the letter
happily shouting his name before hugging
him power tells dingy that she was able
to save him with dingy responding that
he was fine and not in need of saving as
he had already accomplished all of his
dreams going on to say that his life
with power had been like a dream
comparing to the time that he had with
the mafia he tells you again that he was
fine and that nothing good would ever
occur in his life again
power yells at dingy though calling him
a dummy asking him if he truly missed
her so much that he couldn't do anything
he responds that he did and power calls
him a fool for not wanting to do so
she goes on to tell him that devils went
to hell after dying on earth and that
when they died they would most likely be
enemies if they ever met again and
despite this he needs to find whatever
she has become and befriend it to turn
it back into the real power so that they
can be buddies again power then forms a
contract with denji giving him the last
of her blood in return for finding the
blood devil again dingy wakes and the
dumpster bolting upright as he shouts
for power he bends over clutching his
heart as he thinks of her
his grieving though is interrupted as
kashibe is revealed to be sitting down
beside the dumpster as deji turns to
look at him kojiba asks if he was either
dingy or the chainsaw and states if he
was truly dingy then he would help give
him some way to escape from makima dinji
stands silent for a moment before
showing kishibe the peace symbol as a
way to prove it's our goofy ass boy
koshiba leads denji and kabini into an
underground safe house give any comments
on how having witnessed mahima's attack
she will likely be hunted down and asks
kashibe if she'll ever be able to
contact her family again he tells her
probably not to which she responds with
relief which leaves dingy surprised but
kabini explains that she no longer has
to contact her family which kind of
makes her happy
as the two sit kibindi begins to cry
explaining her fears of death and
telling denji that she is jealous of his
reincarnation abilities then she replies
that though he is physically fine he is
an emotional wreck and is coming to
terms with the fact that he had lived
his entire life and subservience to
others never making any significant
choices of his own kabini responds that
such a life a life full of hardships and
unhappiness is normal stunning him as he
stares at her in shock he comments on
how he wanted to be normal to which she
responds with confusion
suddenly dingy's attention is drawn to a
nearby tv on which news reports
discussing the chainsaw man are playing
the tv discusses the chainsaw man's
heroic deeds showing a number of people
cheering and celebrating him dingy
watches and stunned silence quietly
whispering that's me to himself
he exclaims that everyone was praising
him before holding up a hand to his face
holding back tears as he shouted that he
was popular watching as a girl on the
screen waved a sign asking for chainsaw
man to go out with her sitting back in
the armchair behind dingy kishibe opens
his eyes before telling dingy to quiet
him down then she tells him that he was
tired of eating things like bread and
jam for breakfast and instead wanted to
eat steak every day in its place he
cries about how he can't and shouldn't
wish for such things as he collapses
onto his hands and knees in front of
kishibe saying how he wanted to have
five no ten girlfriends and that he
wanted to have lots of demonetisation
stuff dingy slowly pulls himself back up
before exclaiming that he wanted to be
chainsaw man for those reasons khasheba
sit silently for a moment before telling
denji that makima would find and kill
him if he attracted too much attention
telling him that the next time he
entered his hybrid form would be the
time she would kill him at some point
later in the night dingy continues to
watch the television as kashibe and
kabini sleep he tells himself that he
definitely wanted to become the chainsaw
man and asks himself how he was going to
kill makima he knows that she wasn't
someone he could win against without a
plan and tries to think about some way
he could defeat her his mind is soon
filled with the memories of his time
with public safety as he thinks back on
the encounter with the darkness devil
his first time meeting bame and his
fight against santa claus denzi's mind
is then filled with the memories of
makima with images of her face appearing
from when she told him she'd grant him
any wish if she'd killed the gun devil
when she introduced him to her pet dogs
when she laughed in his lap after he
asked her if killing power was a dream
when she fed him her blood during the
fight against santa claus when she
listened to his heart when she told him
what he would be able to eat for
breakfast if he became her dog when she
licked a lollipop before giving it to
him as an indirect kiss and when she
told him that she liked some boy named
dingy
dingy looks down in defeat muttering to
himself that he was the worst and that
even after everything makima had done to
him he still couldn't help but like her
at some point in the future during the
daytime dingy in his hybrid form sits
upon a cross in the graveyard with
makima the katana man rezay quan chi the
whip hybrid the spear hybrid the berserk
hybrid the flamethrower hybrid and
several dozen members of public safety
walking up to him along a dirt path
makima walks up to denji as she takes
note of his weaker form before asking if
he finally came to die for her then she
gets up from the cross before asking
makima if there would be any crappy
movies in her vision of a utopian world
making you realize that it was in fact
dingy there and not the true chainsaw
man form she responds that she believed
it would be for the best if bad movies
were erased from the world to which
dingy says that he has no choice but to
kill her monkey massaged before telling
dingy that everything about him was not
fit for the chainsaw man four crows are
shown flying up into the sky as denji
spins up his chainsaws facing makima
while she approaches him along with the
hybrids and many other members of public
safety zombies suddenly come up from the
graves around dingy as the zombie devil
appears now also behind makima these
zombies begin to rush at dingy from all
sides then she sticks his arms into the
ground shooting his chains down and
wrapping them around a large chunk of
earth before pushing them up launching
several zombies and a massive rock into
the air behind them pulling the chunk of
ground in front of him and throwing it
towards makima katana man and the long
sword hybrid leap into the ear both
slicing the chunk of land and cutting it
down into several smaller chunks the two
now vulnerable in the air watch as denji
appears from behind the debris before
cutting them both with his chainsaws
this spear hybrid leaps up from behind
genji before skewering him with his
chest rize and the whip hybrid both fly
towards dingy yelling out a battle cry
as he spins in the air slicing rezay
with one of the chainsaws on his arms
and cutting the whip in spare hybrids
with the one on his legs dingy and the
slumped bodies of all the hybrids he
just dunked on then fall to the ground
konji appears from behind dingy shooting
him with her arrows these zombies rush
in grabbing him as more and more jump
atop him quickly forming a large pile as
he becomes trapped beneath them makima
and the flamethrower hybrid watched the
zombies where they flame through
unnoting how dingy was much weaker than
he was before makima says that this was
because the entire world was embracing
chainsaw man and spreading his image
even going as far as turning him into a
merchandised character and that there
was no longer a need to fear him still
they flown through a hybrid points his
arms towards the pile before shooting it
with his flames torching it as all of
these zombies begin to burn makima kwon
shi and the flame thrower all stand free
moment as they watch the flames the
flamethrower hybrid yells out in
surprise as two chains shoot out from
the flaming mass each wrapping around a
grave marking behind him before dingy
retracts them launching himself towards
and cutting the flamethrower hybrid in
half as kwanji blocks him with her arms
then she slices at her and manages to
decapitate kuan xi but still several
more arrows pierce him a bloody dingy
falls on his knees then onto his back as
makima stands above him looking down on
him before pointing her finger at her
left palm and saying bang as she shoots
a hole through it she holds her bleeding
palm above dingy's mouth letting the
blood spilling from it fall into his
mouth she then demands that he wake up
as she wanted to trade blows with him so
that she could kill him personally as a
bunch of public safety members float up
behind makima chains appear moving out
from their torsos and connecting them to
her
makima pulls on dingy's chest cord
gracing him before he immediately
decapitates her her head flies off but
due to the chains instead the head of
one of the public safety members
suddenly flies off as machima's head
moves back to her body then she tries to
strike at her again with his left arm
missing as makima dodges and punches him
in the face knocking him back but denji
still manages to slice open her chest
with his right arm then again the injury
is transferred to another public safety
member as makima once again regenerates
she unleashes a flurry of punches
consecutively hitting dingy in the chest
as blood sprays from his mouth though he
still somehow manages to slice her head
off a headless makima kicks dingy in the
chin knocking him back as her head
begins to return to her neck as makima's
head reattaches she punches one of
denji's arms off destroying it she aims
to punch him again as a chainsaw appears
from dingy's leg kicking her and slicing
her in half makima's torso and lower
half quickly reattach as she turns
around punching a hole straight through
denji's torso she swings around to the
front grabbing on to a chunk of guts
spilling out of him before punching him
again tearing through his chest as both
of his arms are ripped off oh my god the
actual brutality of that sentence when i
finally when i finally said it correctly
was mental makima holds onto dingy's
armless corpse from the handle of his
head pulling out pachita with her right
arm as she slowly pulls pochita out from
his body she tells dingy that dingy was
not the chainsaw man
she asks how she could possibly get him
to completely give up on living and how
she could ever possibly get chainsaw man
back then she responds by spitting blood
on her face she continues by saying that
chainsaw man didn't wear clothes or
speak and that he only made a mess out
of everything he did she says that even
with all of denji's ignorance he was
still chosen as the chainsaw man and
that since he was standing between
mahima and him he must die makima fully
rips pochita from danji's chest blood
spurting from his wounds as he coughs up
blood his head then falls back onto the
ground with makima standing above him
staring down at his motionless corpse
makima walks through the graveyard
stepping through the various bodies of
deceased public safety members as she
reaches down and picks up a pack of
cigarettes from the inside of one of the
suit's jackets okay i'm not even giving
this fake ass arky wannabe right now the
time of day she's trying to smoke and
she can't even handle one path like what
even is this anyway one puff andy puts
out the smoke before packing up pochito
and telling him that it was now the
second time she had ever defeated him
and that now he belonged to her she
tells him that they would be together
forever now that eat a lot together
sleep together and live happy together
forever
several feet behind makima the goat
himself actually managed to play the
silly witch denji slowly stands up from
amongst the pile of corpses he slowly
walks over to makima and as she notices
them he takes out a normal chainsaw and
slices her down their freaking chest
makima gasps confused and shocked as
blood spews from her torso falling to
her knees as dingy now stands above her
in a complete role reversal denji
exclaims that makima had finally let her
guard down and tells her that he would
now be taking pochita back he reaches
down picking up pochetta as he says that
what he just did now was dangerous and
that he had used up all of the blood
power had given him from their contract
revealing how he'd actually managed to
survive without his heart because
technically power was his heart and like
honestly i freaking love that sophie
[__] man katsuki fujimoto had different
with that one mahima now bleeding from
her mouth and nose asks how dingy was
alive to which dingy responds that she
had actually been fighting pochita the
entire time as mahima continues to bleed
then she tells her that the chainsaw he
had just cut her worth was made out of
the blood that he had got from power and
that he was making it run a muck inside
of her makima says this is hardly enough
too to which dng cuts her off and says
that he didn't believe he could truly
kill her was such a cheap trick and
honestly you guys are not ready for what
is about to happen like at all i mean at
all you have no idea what is about to
happen unless you have already read it
you have no idea like you don't even you
don't even have this in the most foreign
region of your brain that this idea
would happen at the moment so just be
[__] really this is about to happen
okay okay
a van pulls up behind denji leading him
to happily exclaim that master kishibe
was there to pick them up he tells
makima he's sorry before
later on a short of tokyo is shown with
various citizens shown to be going about
their day the scene transitions to night
in the exterior of a run-down apartment
building with kishibe's van parked
outside inside a room kishibe complains
that his back hurt before asking dingy
if he was ready and as dinji says that
he was kishibe tells him that from there
onward it was personally up to him he
tells him that innocent people were
dying as they speak and that it would be
best if dingy could finish as quickly as
possible yet denji says that he'll be
going at his own leisurely pace kishibe
then tells him one last thing he didn't
believe that what denji was about to do
would truly work and that he should be
prepared for failure and death then she
tells him that he himself was the one
who came up with the idea so he was
already prepared kishibe leaves as he
tells dinji that he'd be back by again
if he was still alive and tells him to
not die as out of everyone he'd ever met
dingy was the most suited for being a
devil hunter i freaking love that old
man the door to the apartment closes as
dingy talks to himself and walking to
the refrigerator mumbling that he was
very hungry he pulls a small box out of
the meat stacked fridge because you know
gotti good for real then stingy says
that even after everything that happened
he still liked makima he begins to cook
saying that he couldn't forgive makima
after everyone she'd killed he says that
because of that he'd share the burdens
of her sins with her and asks himself
how he would truly do that he toys with
the idea of latching themselves onto a
bomb and performing a double suicide
before countering it with the fact that
all previous physical attacks had no
effect on her but says that that fact is
what read him to realise how to beat her
and how to become one with her
dingy then finishes preparing his meal
which consists of a small bowl of white
rice miso soup and ginger fried meat and
onions then in the normal japanese style
he performs itadikimasu before taking a
sip of the miso soup and noting that it
was extremely good
very tasteful he takes a bite of the
ginger fried meat and onions and says
that it tastes alright he begins to take
a bite of the rice as he knows that what
he was tasting was what mahima tasted
like if you catch my damn drift oh my
god i couldn't stop laughing at this
[__] when i first read it like how
well did tatsuki fujimoto manage to hide
that up into the last line dingy the
only way he gets rid of makima is by
eating her i love it it's so good later
on now and in a park kishibe sits on a
bench drinking as then she walks towards
him with all seven of makima's dogs and
meowi on his head then she sits down
next to kishibe on the bench letting a
few kids come and play with their dogs a
young girl then approaches them and says
dog ease dingy tells keshibe that he had
eaten all of makima and that she hadn't
revived kishibe then asked stenshi how
he had killed her despite the fact that
attacks had no effect on her to which
danger responds that he honestly didn't
want to hurt mahima that him eating her
and becoming one with her wasn't even an
attack but rather love i guess
kishibe tells him that he probably just
ended up accidentally finding a way
around her contract before asking dingy
how he managed to attack makimo without
her detecting him dingy explains that
makima only perceived people through his
sense of smell and because of that he
bet that mahima only saw chainsaw man
the entire time he'd known her and never
truly took notice of him which is
freaking deep bro like who knows if they
after their chainsaw clout for real the
young girl moves closer to pet creampuff
leaving denji to tell her that he and
kishibe were having a top secret
conversation and that she needed to beat
it the young girl walks up to denji
before biting his finger quickly leading
denji to recognise her bite as maki miz
the young girl looks up at denji showing
him that her eyes also have the same
target-like pattern as makima's kishibe
tells denji that the young girl had been
recently discovered in china and that he
had stolen her oh yes of course typical
old man stealing a child he tells him
that the young girl wasn't makima but
just the control devil and that no
memories from mahima were in the girl he
says that if they left the young girl in
the hands of the bureau she'd inevitably
become just like makima again kishiba
ends off by telling dingy that he would
be leaving the reborn control devil in
his hands as he was going to be really
busy for the foreseeable future dingy
asks the young girl what her name was to
which she responds that her name was
nayuta then she sighs and asks her if
she wanted to do anything other than eat
meat
she responds that she wanted to eat
sliced bread prompting dingy to say that
she was a pretty inexpensive devil to
keep around he then walks back to his
apartment walking the dogs with him as
nayuta rides on his back back at his
apartment the two eat some sliced bread
before falling asleep with naota
sleeping in denji's futon while denji
sleeps directly on the floor using one
of their dogs as a palohu then she
begins to dream and inside of his dream
he finds himself holding pochita as the
two sit within the shed they lived in
during dingy's time within the mafia
pochetta tells denji that his dream was
to be hugged by someone and his strength
made it hard for anyone to want to hug
him patrita thanks dingy for making his
dream come true then goes on to ask
denji if he could fulfill the control
devil's dreams too a dream of building
an equal relationship with other people
makima had this dream but couldn't
accomplish it since she only formed
relationships through the power of fear
and because of that grew yearning for
something like a family over time
bushido tells dingy that he wants him to
make the dream come true for naota to
which then she asks how and patrita
tells him that it could be done through
giving her lots and lots of hugs which
obviously just correlates to a good
upbringing difficult japanese manga who
could have ended in a hella sus way but
yeah obviously because of her previous
upbringing with the bureau she turned
into the manipulative control freak that
she was and at the moment she's just a
normal control freak but finally as we
start off the new series at some point
in the future a large deformed devil
rampages through the streets of tokyo
chasing innocent civilians several
rumors about the chainsaw man are heard
spreading that killing devils was just
his hobby that he only saved cute girls
if he was truly a human and that he was
just a high school student but standing
there against the crowd we find dingy
face to face with the approaching devil
he stands alone wearing his high school
uniform and beginning to pull the kill
switch on his chest
so
that officially brings us to the very
very end of chainsaw man's story that is
currently out obviously big o tatsuki
fujimoto is coming through and dropping
part two from this month onwards so
you've all got that to look forward to
from now on i guess i won't be covering
up like chapter by chapter because i
don't do that anymore on my channel
anymore as you guys have uh noticed i
stopped doing tokyo revenges and all
that a long time ago i'm more doing just
the the kind of the story and manga side
of things and kind of enveloping like
the story and trying to bring mangas and
make them more you know uh enjoyable to
watch make it more like like like a
movie in some kind of way you can just
sit back and watch it and relax and
enjoy and i hope you guys have been able
to enjoy you know this video here it's
taken me over like two months or i think
maybe two months more than two months
it's taken so long to actually put this
entire video together or i think it's
almost four hours long now so it's been
you know absolutely amazing all the
support that i've got on my channel
since i started doing these entire story
type ones firstly with that tokyo
avengers video back in the day almost
like six or seven months ago now
probably even longer it's just been
going so quickly and then with the demon
slayer stuff towards the end and like
start of this year it's just been
absolutely amazing so i'm going to be
doing like bleach and jiu-jitsu kaizen
shibuya arc is going to be coming out
very soon i've been doing that for the
last like two weeks now in preparation
pretty much for jiu-jitsu guys and at
the end of the year and everything
that's been going on which you guys seen
at the moment has just been so damn good
i can't wait to see what uh tatsugi
fujimoto is going to put out for
chainsaw man in these up and coming
weeks like i think what what are we
around the 11th when i'm recording this
kind of like outro bit for the entire
story here so i've got two days before
the chapter does actually release and
i'm super super excited to finally
actually see it but you know enough of
that enough for me rambling you know i'm
glad you all have enjoyed the video if
you want to support me more than
obviously there's my patreon all that
kind of jazz where i'm absolutely
useless at putting my videos up early
but they do come up early sometimes so
you might get lucky who knows who knows
but anyway for now spin your
professional degenerate diabolo and i
will see you all in april
bye